Test for captioning
It is a 5X7 book featureing
color
images.  Imagine it's as tall as
The oldest written is cuneiform
tablet dateed 2040BC.  Comic
books.  We have the world's
largest collection of comic
books, more than 140,000 of them
them.
And we also hold the world's
most extensive newspaper
collection, the oldest original
newspaper is from December 29th,
We have the papers of 23
presidents.  Before people
started putting them in their
own buildings, this is the place
George Washington up to Calvin
Coolidge.
We have the Gutenberg Bible,
which is one of three perfect ve
vellum copyies in the world.
More than 15 million visual
materials including the most
comprehensive international
collection of posters in the
world.  And the most
comprehensive visual record of
the civil war.  Can you imagine
how important the civil war is
in humanityies and the arts and
the fact we have all of this
material on this, photographs
and banned music and all sorts
of things.
The library's Packard camp for
audio visual information and Cul
Culpepepper, has 6 million items
,
including more than 3.6 million
sound recordings and almost
2 million films.
I forgot to introduce myself.
I'm the Susan Vita, the chief of
Congress.  Let me say a couple
of things about the music
collection.  We have more than
25 -- it's the largest music
collection in the world.  We
have more than 25 million items,
8 million pieces of
sheet music, which include --
you can really learn a lot of
things when you look at sheet
music.
Basically what ads were people
people -- you know, were
important in that time.  What
were the clothes that people
were wearing from the covers?
We have -- they depict this
thinking of the Titanic and the
triangle shirt waist fire, 400
songs about baseball, more than
13,000 World War I songs.  The
collection includes an extensive
manuscripts by composeers of the
American musical theater and the
largest collection of any one
kind of musical instrument in
the world and that is the flute.
So let me talk for a second
about the musical theater and
the connections and how you can
use the library.  If you, for
example, were going to encourage
celebrating his 100th
anniversary starting at the end
of this year, but next year in
particularly.  So we have his
collection.  So you can see
music in his hand here and we
have Oliver Smith's collection.
Oliver Smith was -- this is from
On the Town.  We have his
looks like Coney Island.
Anyway, we have things that link
link, and that shows people how
you can use original source
material and get ideas about
other things.
The archive of folk culture is
largest repository of larger
cultural documentation and one
of the largest in the world.  It
of American Indian music and
spoken word, and the earliest
ethnographic field recordings
made anywhere in the world.
Veterans history collects the
storyies of veterans, and to
date
more than 100,000 of them are
here.  The story corps project
is a nationwide grassroots
initiative to record histories
of people like you and me,
ordinary citizens.  How many
stories are probably varied in
the Story Corps archives.
Since 1931 the library provided
books to the blind in Braille
and now on sound recordings.
The talking books and digital
play back equipment.  And we
have the world's largest
collection of cartographic
materials, more than 5.5 million
interesting parts of that is got
the largest collection of fire
insurance maps of cityies and
towns in the United States, and
they are amazing, just to look
at them.  Very easy -- big
enough scale so that they're
easy to read.  You can go back
and see where your grandfather
was, you know, born and lived
and that kind of thing.  It's
just very interesting.
So basically you can kind of
tell that I'm pretty much in awe
of the embarrassment of riches
that we have here, and the only
thing that is disappointing is
that it's not used enough.
So I'm encourageing all of you
to
think about that as you go back
to your own studyies and
creations and also as you en
encourage the people that you
serve to do the same.
Now it is my pleasure to
introduce Rhona from the
Commission.  Her passion for the
reason why the symposium has
come about, and if you know Rhon
Rhona, you know she's a
difficult person to say "no" to.
the best possible program to
motivate you to go out and do
good.  So get ready for a
wonderful experience
, because Rh
Rhona planned it.
To investigate the current state
of the arts in our nation and
explore how the arts connect
with other industryies.  It is
no
wonder that under mischooseed
leadership the NEA ranks first
among small agencies for the
best places to work in the
federal government in 2016 with
great honor and pleasure, I
welcome Jane.
>> Thank you so much. It's
really wonderful to be here.
Thank you.  And I want to thank
the Library of Congress and the
D.C. commission on the arts and
humanityies for inviting me to
speak today.  Arts education is
a topic that is very dear to my
heart and it's not just because
I majored in music or majored in
arts education, specifically
music education in college, but
it's because I have known about
the power of what the arts can
do for students that not only
honors the appreciation of art
but it spills over into so many
areas of our daily lives.  My
father was a college professor.
Not in music, but when he died
when I was 9, it was the piano
lessons that I was taking as a
kid that sootheed me.  It was
music that helped me express
myself beyond the use of just
linear everyday conversations
and as a 9-year-old I really
didn't have the full vocabulary
to be able to express my grief
over the loss of a parent and
perhaps many 9-year-olds don't
have that, but I didn't have
enough words since my parents
who were from China spoke
Mandarin at home and I, who was
born in Oklahoma and grew up in
Arkansas spoke English at school
school, but the arts were there
for me.
So throughout my growing-up
years, I participateed in as
many
arts activities I could find
from music camps and singing and
choirs and acting and theater
productions to drawing every day
day, and today -- to this day as
an adult, I still draw every day
day.  So through my growing up
years, I became intellectually
interested in it to the point I
majored in music in college.  So
participateing in the arts gave
me another vocabulary set.  It's
to create and also live in the
moment, where I was so immerseed
time stood still.  The arts
helped me navigate through those
because I had the power to make
each of us feel like we belong.
when we're standing in the midst
of living with multiple
perspectives and different
opinions.
The arts give us tools for self-
self-expression when words alone
are not enough.  They help
channel our emotions no matter
how messy or confusing into
something beautiful rather than
something destructive.  The arts
help to empower us, to imagine
new possibilityies for what we
might achieve.  So everybody who
has participateed in the arts
has
likely experienced these effects
effects, and all of you I'm sure
body of research about arts
education that confirms what we
instinctively know, that
children and teenagers who
participateed in arts education
programs were associateed with
more positive academic and
social outcomes than students
who did not participate in those
programs.  And this was
especially true for youth who
came from households with very
few social or economic
opportunities.  Eighth gradeers
from low socioeconomic homes
were active in the arts in
elementary school showed higher
test scores in science and
writing than students who were
not active in the arts.  High
schoolers from low socioeconomic
calculus course than students
with no arts-rich experiences.
And across the board, arts
engage students showed higher
overall grade point averages and
higher GPAs were found with
all students who participateed
in the arts regardless of where
students came from, regardless
if they came from low socio
socioeconomic homes or high
socioeconomic homes versus
students who did not participate
students who earned few to no
arts credits were associateed
with being five times more
likely not to have graduateed
than students who earned many
arts credits.  The arts-rich
students in high school were
more likely to go to college,
more likely to enroll in four-
four-year colleges, more likely
to get a bachelor's degree, more
likely to earn mostly As in
college, more likely to involve
themselves in the community,
more likely to read the
newspaper at least one time in
the day.  More likely to
participate in student
government and service clubs,
volunteer, vote, especially
those from low socioeconomic
background.  And by the way, you
can find all of this research
along with hundreds of other
arts education studies online at
artsedsearch.org and today I'm
drawing mostly from the work of
Dr. James Catterall.  You get
the idea, there's a strong
relationship between children
and teens who have high levels
of arts engagement and positive
outcomes from their lives versus
engagement, especially those who
are challengeed with fewer
social
and economic resources.
So what this means is that by
closing the gaps in terms of who
has access to arts education and
who does not, we're also helping
to close the broader achievement
gaps that exist in our
educational system.  So if we're
playing field, for you who come
from low socioeconomic household
households, then we need to get
serious about providing equal
access to the arts, because the
arts are not a matter of -- it's
there's room in the budget.
They are a necessity that is the
across the United States reach
their full potential in their
every moments and for their
successful futures.  I know that
humanityies understands this and
I want to applaud their efforts
to bring the arts to all D.C.
students, because the D.C.
Commission is one of the main
supporters of the D.C. Arts and
Humanityies Arts Collaborative,
and this is the newest member of
the Kennedy's Center Any Given
Child Program and the first to
span grades K-12 to help
communities expand access to
arts education, and we really
are looking forward to seeing
the results here in Washington,
because this program is going to
collective impact grant from the
National Endowment For the Arts.
And part of this brings together
parents, students, administrator
administrators, along with the
D.C. Commission and the Kennedy
Center to develop an arts
education agenda for Washington,
Washington, D.C. as well as
specific measureable goals for
how the agenda will be achieved.
We envision a day when all
communities make arts education
a priority, just as D.C. is
doing, and over the past five
decades the National Endowment
for the Arts invested
244 million in arts education
projects across the United
States and these projects range
from in-school performances and
artist residencyies, after
school
arts programs for students,
professional development for
teachers, collective impact
projects, such as the one I just
collaborative collective impact
group.  We must thrive and we
must strive to empower every
child in this country with an
excellent arts education.  40%
of our arts education grants are
also launching a state-wide data
infrastructure project in every
single state that helps identify
arts education opportunities for
students so we can help there,
and this is in cooperation with
the education commission of the
states.
So you get the idea.  We believe
it's a big job and I do want to
introduce Iona Hudson.  Will you
arts education.  And if you have
any questions... yes, she
deserves that applause.  If you
have questions about arts
education or grants relateed to
that email Iona and she will
guide you through the process.
You can email her at 3:00 in the
morning if you want to and she
she'll...
[ Laughter ]
You're welcome.  Oh, there's
Nancy daughtery.  Nancy, stand
as well.  We have a wonderful
team.  And so feel free to
connect with them throughout the
you.
This is a big job.  Providing
equal access to the arts require
requires input at every level,
parents, teachers, local, state,
national leaders, principals,
superintendents, and so I'm
hopeful that we're going to
reach a day where the country
embraces the arts as a
fundamental and indispensable
part of our children's success,
because arts education is not
about -- just about children
learning how to finger a B flat
on a trumpet -- that might be
nice -- it's not just learning
how to pirouette, although that
might be nice, or using water
colors to paint a picture of a
tree -- that might be nice.
Arts education is about giving
students a tool belt of skills
that allow them to reach their
full potential where children
can achieve academiccally and
socially and where they can
imagine a world beyond what they
might know and dream of new
possibilityies for themselves
and
where they can express their
ideas beyond the use of linear
everyday conversations and they
can develop self-confidence and
discover that they really do
belong and communicate with
others and reach those who have
perspectives different from
their own and innovate and
create.  Because we know that
whenever we create, we move away
door to solveing those old and
tired problems in new and
positive and meaningful ways.
The United States has always
been a nation of innovators and
visionaryies and instilling the
arts in hour students. will help
ensure that this legacy remains
in place.  I want to thank
everybody here today for
recognizing the importance of
arts education and working so
hard to ensure a promising
future for all of our children.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Thank you, Jane, for an
inspireing and lovely speech.  I
off with our first panel, the
introduction to this will be
Arthur Espinoza, executive
director of the D.C. Commission
on the Arts and Humanities.
[Applause]
>> Good morning!
>> Morning!
>> It's Monday and there's so
many beautiful people in the
room.  All gathered for one
great idea.  I'm so excited
about this.  As we said before,
we weren't sure if this was
still up and I'm so excited that
it had.  Welcome to all of you
on behalf of the Commission of
the Arts and Humanities and I
want to thank the Library of
Congress for their help.  We
appreciate your coordination in
this event.  In particular,
Susan Vita and LeeAnn Potter, as
appreciateed.  If there's
standing room I'll do
housekeeping, there's extra
seating back over here as well,
so I want to make sure everybody
is comfortable, can see and hear
clearly.  We're in for a lot
today and we hope that you'll
find good things out of it.
I also would like to thank the
Library of Congress for opening
up what is a little information
about the treasure chest of this
building.  It is just amazing to
hear Ms. Vita talk about the
things one can access here,
which I think we know about but
we forget about sometimes or we
don't always have time.  So I
ask that you consider your
opportunities there and how that
may be able to help inform your
work.
I would like to recognize as we
did already, Kay Candle, chair
of the commission.  Also
Gretchen, one of our
commissioners and Hailey Francis
Francis.  And I missed a
commissioner, I hope you will
forgive me.  But welcome.  We're
to the staff, as we mentioned
before, and Dr. Jeffrey Scott,
David Marky, arts education
department, thank you for your
hard work today putting it
together, and thanks to Dr. Jane
And leading us with your work at
the National Endowment for the
Arts, and it's an honor to work
alongside them.  As a state
agents we have the opportunity
to partner with the NEA to carry
out their initiative as well as
our own and we're pleased to
work with them and all the staff
from the NEA.  Welcome to all of
you here from the NEA.  I think
I saw a few, but I know there's
probably others.  Great to see
you.
I also want to repeat a little
bit about what Dr. Chu said.  I
think you heard the value of the
arts education and the value how
that starts to change our
society and our community.  We
know these things that are
really critical to what we're
doing are really critical to the
communities that we live in, and
they're also to business very
valuable.  Things such as
creative thinking and critical
skills that you have to help
inform your work, whether you
stay in the arts or not.  Now,
we hope everyone here continues
to have that lifelong experience
it also helps bring valuable
skills to teamwork and in a
workplace, in a business setting
setting, that's a really
valuable asset for us to have.
And the arts help us learn that.
is going to provide you with a
lot of information about how you
practice, whether you're
interested in trying to find way
ways to empower students or
whether that's simple the work
that you're doing to find
equitable participation in the
schools and help us break down
those barriers that exist in the
aspects that we want to address
and the arts really do help us
do that.  Student success and
achievement is critical and also
the District of Columbia has
been supportive of the efforts
we carry out and that you all
carry out in arts education.  I
want to thank her for continueed
support of the Commission and
for her continueed support
especially of arts education.
We apressure crate all she's
doing to support us.
I hope there will be great in
insights and we're going to get
going now with the first panel.
talking, so now we're ready to
start listening to others to
invite us to think more deeply.
Helping us do that is our
special guest and moderator for
the first panel, senior vice
president for education at the
John F. Kennedy Center for the
Performing Arts Mario Rossero.
I don't say that much.  You
probably say it all the time.
[Applause]
>> Good morning. It's great to
join you.  I feel like it's an
arts education family reunion
moments.  I have one of the best
jobs in the world.  I get to
lead the education efforts at
the Kennedy Center for the
Performing Arts, local, regional
my colleagues who have done a
great job to set the table I
think for today's conversation,
but first I want to thank Rhona
and the Commission for the
invitation to join today.  You
may not know that this past May
was 100th birthday of President
Kennedy.  For the Kennedy Center
Center, many know us for the
world class performing arts on
our stages but we also uplift
the ideals from President
Kennedy's legacy of service,
justice, freedom, courage and
gratitude through the arts,
through the memorials that the
building really is to him.  But
the Kennedy Center is more than
just a building or address.  It
It's also this ideal, and it's
an ideal that the arts are
really for everyone, so as a
nation's cultural center we feel
shoulders to make sure that
we're fighting alongside all of
our colleagues in this room to
make sure the barriers to access
experiences are available to all
all.  It's my team's charge to
make sure we lock arms with
colleagues here and across the
country and we take a lot of
time to identify and know what
the problems and challenges in
the field of arts education and
arts learning are as well as
some of the best practices, and
we're really lucky to have the
support and resources to create
some model programs that can try
out some solutions to those
problems, right?  Because
everybody in this room, we stand
on the shoulders of a history of
work and effort to really tackle
this problem, right?  And I
would like to acknowledge
everyone who spent the last 20,
30, 40, 50 years really working
at this and I think it takes
everyone working together in
lockstep to add are dress the
arts education challenges and
it's a cross-sectoral challenge,
but I am inspired and excited we
can do it together and I think
the voices that we're going to
hear from today give us a range
of perspectives and what we're
going to hear about is not just
about equity, access and
innovation in arts and arts
education but it's rooted in
some exemplar, best practices,
really looking at the evidence
and demonstration of the power
of the arts.
So if you would join me in a
round of applause, I'm going to
welcome our panelists up to the
stage.  So I'm going to talk a
little bit and buy time as they
make their way up, but maybe
we'll have continuous round of
applause.  We have Dr. Alexander
Hopkins.
We have Christopher K. Morgan
from Dance Place, local arts
organization.
My good friend Nathan Diamond
from D.C. public schools who
leads the arts charge for the
district, and we have Asha
Gardner from Split This Rock.
[Applause]
Before we jump into our
conversation, we always believe
that it is a good
idea to start
with the arts.  Alex was willing
Take it away.
Gallatin
>> Before we get started, my
goal is to really have a great
conversation with everyone but
leave time at the end for
audience questions, so as you
listen, think about anything
that might be on your mind that
you want to go deeper in, so
please consider that.  Also
everyone's bios are in your
program book, so you might go
deeper to find out about folks
there, and I was asked to make
sure everyone has their cell
phones on silent before we start
our conversation.  Thank you for
that.
So let's start with you.  Thank
you for that bevel piece and
shareing your artistic talents
as
well, but we love the idea about
overlapping, we actually find a
lot of connections between all
the art forms and health and
wellness, but we know you eave
got a particular interest and
focus in music and wellness and
health, so I wonder if you might
give us a context about your
work and some of the findings
and things you're finding
interesting right now in your
work.
>> Thank you very much. It's
my pleasure to be here this
morning in front of this full
room.  I do have a sense that
I'm preaching to the choir, but
it's nevertheless very important
important.
As you can tell music is near
and dear to me.  For my patient
patient's sake, I hope I'm a
better physician than I am a
musician, but I've been playing
the violin since I was seven, so
including a public school and
elementary school, I still
remember my orchestra days
playing William Tell Overture.
It played a central role in my
life, but what I want to say a
few words about now is that
research over the last five to
seven years has actually
provided evidence for the
importance of music education
and it's linked to success
throughout the lifetime of a
person, and particularly
academic achievement.
So there was a hypothesis put
forth by Dr. Patel from Tufts
University and published in
Frontiers of Psychology in 2011
and it's easy to remember,
because the acronym of the
hypothesis is OPERA., and that I
has been done in the last five
to six years.
The OPERA hypothesis proposes
that benefits -- possible
benefits of music are driven by
elasticity test in the speech
processing parts of the brain.
The brain networks networks for
speech,
and this occurs when five
conditions are met.  So that's
the acronym.  And they are O for
emotion, R for repetition and A
for attention.  There is an
anatomical overlap in the brain
networks that process sound
features used in both music and
speech.  For example, the
amplitude of the sound waves as
well as the periodicity which
the sound waves appear.  P
stands for precision.  Music
places higher demands on the
shared networks when compared to
musical activityies that engage
this network can elist very
strong emotions.  I don't know
how many of you have had the
experience of feeling chills or
shivers up and down your spine
when you're listening to a
pleasurable piece of music.  Of
course, one size does not fit
all.  It's very individual.  But
scientificcally demonstrateed in
the last six years or so that
powerful emotional centers are
activateed when listening to
music.  R stands for repetition.
engage this network connected to
speech are frequently repeated
as we're listening and as we're
practicing an instrument or
singing, and that repetition is
crucial to success.  And finally
A for attention.  Musical
activityies that engage in that
work I'm talking about are
associateed with focused
attention, and, of course, you
have to pay attention as we're
learning musical instrument.
So according to the OPERA
hypothesis, when these condition
conditions are met, neural
plasticity, long-term changes in
the brain drives these networks
to function with higher
precision that is needed for
ordinary speech communication,
however, since speech shares
these networks with music,
speech benefits in a secondary
way.  The processing of speech
itself.  And so the OPERA
hypothesis has been used to
account for superior encodeing
of
speech in musically trained
individual, which I won't have
time to go into in detail today,
but I'm happy to answer
questions about.  And this
suggests mechanisms by which
musical training could improve
the linguistic reading ability.
So I'm just going to run through
literally the headlines of study
studies published in the last
five or six years and there's
one particularly relevant study
by Kraus from Northwest
University in Chicago that I
want to focus on a couple
minutes.  So thus far studies
have shown that babies, one
one-year-olds who have music
lessons with their parents tend
to smile more and earlier and
communicate better.  Music
training can improve white
matter connectivity, the highway
highways in our brain that
connect the thinking gray matter
areas enable rapid millisecond
level processing, they are
actually strengthened as a
result of musical training.  Not
active musical training
participation.  So I could go
into details if you're interest
interested as far as how long it
one year sometimes, one year to
15 months of musical training,
changes are seen in the brain.
Where the changes seen?  The
corpus collosum, main white
matter highway connecting the
two hemispheres, the two halves
of the brain, that's actually
made thicker, strengthened
strengthened as a
result of musical training over
time.  And the articula, the
left side of the brain serves as
the main connection between the
areas understanding language and
as well.
Blood flow in the
brain in some of the speech
areas I mentioned  in the OPERA
hypothesis is increased real
realtime
pack clickcally as a result of
music training and exposure.
exposure. executive function,
point A to point B to point C,
multitaskingtasking, so crucial
in
their world, that improves as a
result of musical training over
time.  The gray matter, not just
in the cortex, the outer part of
the brain, are actually made
bigger as a result of musical
training and exposure.
Verbal memory and childhood
literacy is actually improved
over time as a result of classes
classes, exposing people to
music.  And this is not just for
lifetime, as we age, there's now
several studies that show that
the brain plasticity is benefit
benefited by musical training
throughout the lifetime.  And,
in fact, this is now beginning
to be thought as a protective
measure, playing a musical
instrument against cognitive
aging, mild cognitive impairment
impairment, dementia of the
Alzheimer's type and otherwise.
What I want to emphasize a
little bit more, that's Dr. Nina
is that it actually may --
musical training in school may
actually help reduce academic
achievement gaps, and August
August 2014 report from the
American Psychological
Association stated that learning
to play a musical instrument or
to sing disadvantaged children
strengthened reading and
language skills which may reduce
These findings involved hundreds
of children participating in
musical training programs in
both Chicago and Los Angeles
public schools.  The positive
role that musical training can
have for youth living in
impoverished areas was presented
by Dr. Kraus in 2014 at the
American Psychological
Association annual convention.
The research concluded that
musical training can enhance the
way children's nervous systems
process sounds in busy or
chaotic environments like a
classroom or playground.  After
just two years of musical
training, not one -- she looked
at one and also two years --
after two years of musical
training, the children's brain
responses to sounds were faster
and more precise than in
students who had other types of
enrichment classes, so this was
not just comparison of music
classes to nothing.
The improved neural function
caused by music training may
lead to enhanced memory and
attention span which in turn can
make it easyier for kids to stay
focused  in the classroom and
improve their communication
skills.  Other separate studies
over the last five to six years
have shown that arithmetic
performance, achievement in
verbal skills, language learning
learning, and even second,
foreign language acquisition,
which I argue is increasingly
important in our globalizeed
world, that actually can be made
before that music a language all
its own.  There's actually
neural anatomical, neural
biological truth to that, and we
know that with each additional
language acquired, it becomes
easyier to acquire the
subsequent
language.  Even if it's not
connected in any way to the
languages you already know.
So research has shown that there
of children raised in impoverish
impoverished environments that
affect their ability to learn,
while more affluent students do
better in school than kids from
lower income backgrounds we
start to find that musical
training can alter the nervous
system to create a better
learner and help offset this
academic gap.
And so I'm happy to talk more,
but I want to make sure that
other panelists have enough time
time.  So I just want to
conclude by saying that evidence
training boosts brain power and
cognitive function in children
and adults, neural enhancements
that are gained through the
musical training early in life
can extend throughout the
lifespan and into old age and
hopefully these findings can
inspire parents and policymakers
to advocate for musical training
in school as enjoyable and
fulfilling outlet that also has
the power to boost our brain
strength and improve reading,
writing and arithmetic.  There
are data that actually need to
be expanded upon that all
aspects of the SAT are improved
20 to 30 points when compareing
kids who have had music classes
regularly throughout school to
those who have not.  So it seems
brain -- helps keep our brain
sharp as we age and could be an
integral part of rehabilitative
programs for older adults as
well with cognitive decline.
>> Thank you, Alex.
[Applause]
>> I think that's a great
starting with the evidence is a
great place to start.  And I
know everybody in this room is
interested and also chargeed
with
measureing the impact and
telling
the stories of our work, right?
So often we're looking at the
intervention and the classroom
or with kids and we're tracking
that, but I love holding those
outcomes against the science as
well because seems like that
would make a powerful argument.
When prepping for this
conversation, Alex and I had a
brief chat about the Kennedy
Center's work with Renee Fleming
Fleming.  She has ha deep
interest in music and wellness,
right?  So we've done a sound
health initiative and a project
called Music in the Mind, but
she literally had this opera div
diva, MIR singing in aria and
checking brain waves as it's
going, and we saw the
visualization and the most sort
of stark outcome to me was not
when she was singing, it was
preparation to be creativity.
That's when the brain lit up
with most activity, preparation
to create.  Which was interest
interesting.  It resonates when
you think about it, because
you're getting ready, your brain
is getting ready, you're prepare
preparing for that moment Hoff
creation or that act of making.
Really exciting.  Thank you for
starting us off.  Also on this
panel we have experts from
different ar forums, so we know
that every art form makes an
impact on students and we find
at least one but maybe sometimes
multiple ways to express
ourselves and to communicate.
So Christopher, I would like to
turn to you next.  I would love
to hear a little bit about Dance
Place and the role in the
community and just sort of talk
about your work and how it fits
into this conversation.
>> Absolutely. Hello, everyone
everyone, my name is Christopher
Christopher.  My sign name was
given to me by polish deaf
students 20 years ago.  This is
my sign name.  My pronouns are
he/his.  As a native Hawaiian it
it's important for me to connect
recognize we're on stolen land
from native tribes and to bring
my ancestors into the room, it's
nonsecular, about the meeting of
two, land and seas, sky and
water.
[ chanting ]
AlolAAloha, probably the only
Hawaiian word you know.
That's the foundation of equity,
recognizing as many things as I
can sense in one moment, and
that's the foundation of bridge
bridging to youth and just
people in general.
And so for me, you know, the
dance person always has to get a
little interactive.  I would
love to ask for you just sitting
towards the future for me?
Nice.  I love arts people.  It's
want a better survey.  Try to
keep the same answer.  Point
towards the future.
Someone made a dance out of it.
So great.  Just anecdoteally,
what I tended to see was forward
peripheral vision, right?  If
I'm dancing with people in a
line, like the rockettes -- I've
I've
never been a Rockette, but I
dreamed of it, if I'm dancing
with people in a line, I have to
use peripheral vision to sense,
if needed, in unison.  We use
that all the time as lay people
in driving and other daily
skills.  But one of the things
that I think is interesting in
some cultures, the future is
neither forward or up.  It's
back here.  Because you can't
see it yet.  It has not been
revealed to you yet.  However,
there is so much that we have as
intuition, our envelope tint,
our gut.  In Hawaiian it's nuh-o
nuh-ow that allow us to sense
the unseen.  For me a lot about
equity and access is trying to
tune into that.  How do we sense
sense -- sense is related to the
word "sensitive"."  How are we
sensitive to the needs of others
others?  Words we use a lot as
arts educators and advocates.
How do we do that and connect to
that?  So much of that is tune
ing
in and listening, and all art
forms are really good at that,
and that's why so much of that
evidence about how it spans out
into other aspects of our lives,
the scientific, the educational
data, all of those things pay
off because it's allowing us to
tune into others.  So a little
bit about Dance Place.  I'm the
executive artistic director of
Dance Place based in Washington,
Washington, D.C.  It's a 37
37-year-old institution.  And we
we've been in our location in
Brooklyn Edward for 31 years.
Our founding director, Carla Pur
Purlow and co-director Debra
Riley retired and I became the
director after a national search
for a new director last
September.  I'm pretty new to
this role.  Obviously not new to
the arts.  Dance Place, in
addition to presenting theater
that hosts over 45 weekends of
performances each year from
international, national and area
companies and having a school
and having youth enrichment
programs, has been an anchor in
the neighborhood.  When Carla
and the board at the time bought
the building 31 years ago, it
became kind of a galvanizeing
force for that neighborhood and
we all recognized the problems
that come with genetic tri
trification.  We've been pretty
fortunate in the Brooklyn edge
edgewood neighborhood because
history of high home ownership
in that neighborhood and pockets
of development that happened in
the last five to ten years in
particular didn't displace too
many people.  I fear, and think
it might be coming in the future
as development increases, but to
date it hasn't been too jarring.
What's happened in our
neighborhood is our community
has continueed to mix both
economically, racially, and all
kind of definitions of diversity
diversity.
So that's presented Dance Place
with wonderful opportunities in
our different programs to engage
the community to bring them in
and see what happens as a third
space, what can we do when we
bring these different
communities together?
When Carla and the original
Dance Place staff and faculty
were there 31 years ago, a
couple of youth knocked on the
door and just needed a place to
hang out until their parents got
home and they needed a bathroom.
It was a little cold outside.
That literally became the
foundation for our energyizeers
program. our energyizeers
program
serves youth 6-12 and the junior
Naomomi... hi!
She was not expecting that.
These programs are offering life
skills and arts curriculum to
help empower these youth just
like a lot of the work that you
all do does, and give them a
good place to be and good skills
skills.  That program expands
every summer to 75 kids from the
25 that we serve during the
school year, and those kids get
five weeks of programming
throughout the day, that's based
then junior staff program they
work throughout the year, they
have different jobs and roles in
the community at Dance Place and
on our arts campus.  So this is
what our programming looks like.
thinking a little more about
this mixed neighborhood that
we're in, and the challenges
that it presents.  I literally
had some teenage boys yell at me
when I asked them to leave our
arts park at 9:30 p.m. because
the building was closed and it
was time to go home.  They
yelled at me... you're new here.
You don't know what it's like
here.  And I hear that, I
recognize that and I understand
that.  And at the same time how
do we create an environment that
is embraceing of them and
embrace
embracing of these challenges
and also trying to get them to
anchor themselves and go home at
night when that's appropriate.
You know, there's a lot of
reasons why I don't want them on
the street night, not just
necessarily for what they do but
these are the challenges we're
facing there, and how can we
continue to bridge our
curriculum in ways that bring
those different socioeconomic
groups together.  I've anecdote
al
anecdotally noticed in our
tuition-based program which grew
to serve 500 youth to just 300
two years ago that most of our
tuition-based programs racially
look a certain way, because of
new communityies that have moved
into that neighborhood and youth
enrichment programs, racially
look a different way.  How do we
that and create a foundation for
their futures that recognizes
how incredibly mixed our world
is that we live in and provide
tools within which then one or
two sentences they can recognize
the history of where we are, the
diversity in the room and how
hopefully we can sense one
another.  Sensitively.
[Applause]
>>
Christopher you make me
think -- I think you articulate
ed
in a special way, which is, you
know, arts education -- I'm
always a champion of working
from an assets model, right?  So
the struggle, instead of, woe is
me, the struggles we have, think
about the power we have.  I
think uniquely arts education
among other subjects, think
about literacy and math et
et cetera.  Arts education is
really so well poised, both out
of necessity but out of its
ability to not just be about
curriculum and instruction,
right?  Not just about what you
learn in the art form but isn't
it about listening, right?
Isn't it about community?  Isn't
it about bringing things
together, right?  Recognizing
past, present, future.  It has
the ability to do all these
things and sort of knit them
together in a way that I think
really -- especially within the
school, within a neighborhood,
within a program, it's got this
sort of super-power, right, this
perspectives and things together
together.  I don't know that
everyone looks at the other
curricular areas in the same way
way.  I appreciate your
articulation of that.
So Nathan, I've known Nathan a
little while.  We both were in
Chicago public schools fighting
the good fight in arts education
education.  I think we're the
two visual artists up here.
>> Yeah.
>> So Nathan leads the Charge
and the team at D.C. Public
Schools for arts education. so I
initiatives that we're going to
dive into, but I thought you
might just take a moment to sort
of continue the conversation and
talk about the work of equity
and access in your role and with
>> Absolutely. So as said, I'm
the director of arts for D.C.
Public Schools.  So in that role
all disciplines in the arts.  He
also mentioned I'm a visual
artist.  My background is in
photography and design and
prison making, but I'm actually
going to talk -- print making
but I'm going to talk about
music initiative today.
>> I'm just trying to represent
>> Absolutely. And, you know,
it's been great to listen from
Dr. Chu about the idea how we
approach the arts as a language.
sector because literacy has
specific connotations and we are
broaden the scope of what we
talk about when we talk about
literacy in public education,
expanding that into visual
literacy and music literacy.
And so the role I think -- you
know, this idea of equity, these
three words, equity, access,
innovation, could not be more
gift wrapped for the work we're
doing now, because chancellor
Wilson, chancellor of D.C.
public schools has a really
intense focus on equity and how
we are approaching our schools
for what they need and what the
communities need, not just sort
of even strokes, but what
actually do we need to give each
the arts, that comes in a few
different forms.  It's about
exposure and opportunity and I
think those are things that sort
but I think bigger than that,
what we look at is how are we
empowering students to use their
voice?  And so we talk a lot
about the use of a student's
voice and how do we transition
from a skills acquisition model
where we are sort of building
students' capacity up to do
certain things as they get older
older, and more how are we
handing them these tools, giving
them space to use them, to
experiment with them, to
understand them on their own
terms an then guiding them from
there as they get older.  So it
is really how we're being
strategic in that process from
pre-K through 12th grade.
I think critical is, you know,
literacy in the traditional form
students to express themselves,
how can we get them to write
ideas down and speak eloquently
and be sure they can operate in
society, but as we know, the
arts do that incredibly well and
challengeed to be reacheded by
traditional forms of literacy.
And so one of the things that we
hold dear is that if we are not
equitably -- equity and access,
if we're not equityably reaching
students there are voices miss
missing  from our culture and
our society and if we know,
which we do, that a lot of the
issues of success in schools, as
Christopher was talking about
even in the way he sees
differences in his populations,
we know there are a lot of
things that fall along socio
socioeconomic lines, and so it
is clear to us -- we can look at
the research and know the groups
of voices that are actually
missing from our culture that
aren't being expressed, and so
to us the arts is such a
critical place where we have the
potential to start that change,
and Dr. Chu spoke about that
eloquently earlier.
So how we're doing this, we have
half years ago when I came into
this role, I was asked to look
at what the curriculum of DCPS
arts is and how do we write a
curriculum for the future?
And so to Mario's point, the
arts don't live comfortably in
the world of curriculum and
instruction the way traditional
content areas do.  This has a
lots to do with the way we
evaluate and test.  You guys
know.
[chuckles]
Exactly.  So what we said about
doing was changing what a
curriculum looks like.  Can it
meet the needs of a district,
can it look like what a district
needs it to look like, but also
realistically communicate what
it actually is that happens in
an arts classroom, what value
does art add to a student's life
life.  We createed the framework
rooted in root
rooted six themes, and those
span pre-K to 12 and those are
universal themes that we as
human beings explore throughout
our lives, identity, interaction
interaction, language,
determination, creation and
transformation.  It is those six
words that anchor all of the
work that we do and the idea is
that while those are incredibly
complex and deep things that we
all struggle with throughout our
lives, if we can start young
people looking at those things,
developmentally as a five
five-year-old that we are giving
explore what it means to be
human and what they would like
to discover and understand.
[ speaker off microphone ]
>> Certainly can. Identity,
interaction, language,
determination, transformation --
sorry, creation and transform
transformation.
The tricky part is these are
lofty goals and the question
always comes back to:  But how
does that get to a student who
is five years old?  Do we start
talking to them about transform
transformation?  And so I think
what that looks like, then, is
we as the adults are putting
these sort of larger concepts of
our planning, but that doesn't
mean that we aren't also
bringing skills development and
strungture to a young person to
get them there, so it really is
how we are being intentional
that by time a student leaves
D.C. Public Schools we want them
mean but we don't start there.
With we start there in our
thinking but not with young
people.  What it means for young
an arts classroom, the first
thing they should feel is that
what they are doing is
meaningful and matters to them,
that it is connected to their
life, that they feel that they
have a place in what is
happening.  That's our entry
point.  We need to get them
engaged in what is going on.
From there we can -- it's -- you
know, when you have somebody
engaged and ready to learn, it
is much easyier to say, let's
build some skills.  Let's have
some kind of intentional
instruction, because now there's
And then I think the most
critical thing that we infuse
into every piece of curricular
work we do is students must have
playtime.  Technically I don't
call it playtime.  That's what
we call it.  What I call it is
their opportunity to experiment.
things that we are asking them
to come to terms with before --
though is the important part --
before we decide to judge them.
is high stakes, we give them
that space to play, so that we
as educators can watch and
understand where they are, where
they have -- back to the equity
piece, they have what they need
to be successful as individuals.
Lastly I think in that
assessment role, in that time
when we're really looking at how
far can you take this as a young
person, we ask them to use those
skills in unique situations.  We
pose unique problems and ask
them to use the skills to solve
those problems.
So what this looks like in
practice is what I was going to
get to about music is a program
that we launched at the start of
this year called D.C. Keys.
And so this came from an earlier
idea that I had that I was
working on in Chicago and then
brought here, which was about a
middle school initiative to
begin ideas of music production.
How do we not just involve kids
in traditional ensembles, but
how do we get them involved in
the idea of production and
digital production and how do we
start to bridge the relationship
between what is in their
headphones and what happens in
their music class, which both in
my role in Chicago and in my
role here there was a large
disconnect between those two
worlds, so how do we create
bridges?  And the first step was
starting to look at how the
music that they are listening to
you get involved in that
creative process?
It was an early process and like
I said it grew out of something
in Chicago, but it really -- I'm
my -- what I would call my
native discipline.  And so it
wasn't until two years ago when
I was hiring for a music
position, and Ray Muller -- have
somebody wave to over there --
he came in and in his interview,
everything.  He said, we need to
teach kids that music is a
language, it's not something to
be repeated, and they are not
just there to play something
that already has been written.
It is there for them to write.
So I hired him.
[chuckles]
And then I was telling him about
this initiative that I had been
working on that was struggling,
admittedly struggling, and he
said, well, we shouldn't start
in middle school.  We should
start in kindergarten.  It was
instantaneous.
[Applause]
Absolutely.  It solved so many
problems that I was struggling
with, but that I hadn't
identified, which was, one,
music will be a language.  Just
start it from the beginning so
it will be no different.  That's
how it will always be taught.
Two, how do we make sure that
all of our students have
instrumental instruction, which
is incredibly costly and there's
a reason it lives in high socio
socioeconomic neighborhoods?
But in D.C. now we can say with
12 keyboards in every school,
the keyboards we have, 24
students can be playing at any
one time, all of our elementary
students, 25,000 kids are
learning to play the piano as we
speak.
[Applause]
And so it solves that issue of
are we insuring that young
people are learning an
instrument and learning to
perform.  And the last piece is
that it bridges the world of
analog and digital, right?  It
bridges the traditional and
contemporary.  The keyboard is
one that lives like a piano but
can be plugged into a computer.
And so then we can start this
process which the curriculum is
rooted in composition and
improvisation
improvisation.  So our students
starting in kindergarten, the
end of every year, will compose.
Now, we need to shift our ideas
of what composition means, right
right?  There's a new definition
of composition, but we're asking
them to use music as a language
every year that.
The big headline of that, the
piece that matters most to me is
as creative produceers of
culture
culture, not just consumers of
culture.  Which is, I think,
also a big shift in what we're
ing
we'ring.  We're not just -- what
we're doing.  We're not just
trying to make an audience.
We're trying to make people who
create culture later on in life.
either.  I think critical to
this process is that we have
worked very closely with
Washington Performing Arts, many
kind of the broader music
community and to have access to
things that as just a public
school system we don't have
access to.  They have supported
us in the process and worked
with our teachers and stepped up
to say that they will be there
when we figure out what it is
that we actually need from them,
which I think is even more
important.  It's like the blank
check side of it, which is like,
we are here for you when you
know what it is that you need,
just call.  To the point where
this year they have actually
changed their capital arts
programs to meet the needs of
our new curriculum, with an
organization that works in so
many of our schools, that's a
critical relationship that we
have that we can start to mold
how the two organizations work
together.
So to wrap up, I really want you
student here with us,
Jos  Andr
Monta o, School Without Walls at
pianoist, a composeer, just an
an
incredible musician and he
really -- his work exemplifies
what I am talking about, which
is how does music act as an
individual voice?  How do you
create it so that it is your
voice?  And so I'm going to turn
it over to Jos  Andr  to perform
so you can mare what it is that
drives us in my organization to
do the work we're doing for all
of the young people in D.C.
Public Schools.
[Applause]
>> Let's hear it for Jos !
>> Hey, everyone! My name is
Jos  Monta o.  Thank you for
inviting me to the Library of
Congress, for inviting me to
play for you.  It's an honor to
play for you and I'm really
happy to be here with you.
So I wanted to show you -- I
want to play a song that I
really likeed it, and to all the
me.  I want to show you how to
do, like, Nathan was talking
about, how to do, like -- how to
make a new composition, right?
So I will show you some music
for you and this song is called
Sentimental Moon.  I hope you
enjoy it.
[ piano playing ]
[Applause]
>> Bravo!
>> Thank you. Thank you very
much.
>>
Thank you Jose.  We're going
to invite you to join us on
stage.
>> Okay. Of course.
>> While we do that, could we
get a round of applause for Jose
Jose's mom and dad, who always
support him.
[Applause]
>> Thank you. I feel really
lucky.  Jose has had a
relationship with us at the
Kennedy Center for a number of
years and I just got to see you
perform with Renee Fleming a
couple weeks ago and I think he
stole all the attention.  This
kid is a rock star.  We would
love to bring you into the
conversation, Jose, and if you
could talk a little bit about
music in your life and the
importance of it.
>> Okay. Music is important
for me because I think music --
it's a feeling.  It's a feeling
for me, and it brings you a lot
of feelings.  It's really hard
to explain.  But it's important
for me because, for a school, it
helps me improve my education at
school.  It helps
me to get
things that I never got before
and that makes me really happy,
because that is part of -- it
inspires me to
feel doing what
I'm doing.  And as you can see
in the song I just played, it
brings you that feeling, right?
>> Yes.
>> It has to be -- it's really
hard to explain.  Like you have
to --
>> You're doing great.
>> You make the music while
you're playing, and then when I
finish answering that question
question -- when I finish
answering the whole question, I
will show you the same song but
a little bit more faster, so we
can see the difference how you
can transmit a little bit more
better your music.
>> And I wonder if you might...
own, you compose.  There one
that you ear working on now or a
on?
>> Yeah. I already have some
compositions and a couple days
ago, like on Friday -- yeah, on
Friday, I composed a new
composition that it's called --
for my friend Colin, for my
friend from school, one of my
best friends, and a couple days
I composed a song, but it's a
surprise for minimum.
>> Okay. Great. Awesome. We
won't ask more so it can stay a
surprise.  Jose, I'm hoping
you'll stay with us on stage a
few minutes and maybe we can end
going to show us another way to
do it?
>> Yep.
>> So a few minutes of patience
>> Yeah, it's okay.
>> Thank you. Because to your
right we have Asha, who has been
patiently waiting.  I'm so glad
you joined us, Asha Gardner from
to have you jump in the
conversation.  We know you were
born and raised in D.C., right?
>> Uh-huh.
>> Spoken word is a big part of
your life and you grew up with
the program and as well as
working with it now.  Welcome to
the conversation.
>> Hi, guys. I'm Asha fard
never.  I do work with Split
this Rock.  For the past seven
years, since I was 15 -- you
guys do the math yourselves, you
programs with youth, for all
over the city with, I don't know
know, Split This Rock.  I
started in high school.  In high
what I think, I know what I want
want, I know what I need, and I
have to voice it, right?  But in
schools there can be a definite
structure as to how one can
present those needs or how one
can communicate their feelings
or tell your teacher what you
went through at home the other
day, you know?  And I felt for a
while that -- I feel there was
like a disconnect.  I felt like
my school had counselors and
deans of students and vice
principals, but there was no
language to use between us that
would, like, effectively get my
point across, you know, to let
them know that, you know, my
heart hurts today, and I'm sorry
much.  And I found a really
great sponsor in my building,
she was actually the librarian
librarian -- doubles as my mom
mom -- so that's why she was the
best person in the building.
But I kind of found home in the
librairie, you know, and there
was a space where I was sitting
and looking through books and
everything.  It was a space I
could be like, I trust you, you
know, you're an adult in the
building I can trust, aside from
the fact that we're related,
could you please, like, you know
know, listen to me talk about
the things I'm going through
just for a second?  You know,
just with my friends and other
things.  And she would listen to
me all the time but she would
always in the conversation be
like, this is not what I'm here
for.  I'm a librarian.  This is
what I'm supposed to be doing.
And she challengeed me one day.
club.  You and all your friends
come here and sit around and you
together, so why not make it a
real club, you know?  And we
were like, wow, that's a really
great concept.  What kind of
club can we start to, like, talk
about our emotions and things?
And this -- I don't know, the
spirit of art was in the
building because Split This Rock
opening up their new youth
programming with D.C. Slam Team
and bringing back all of their
big movements  in the city and
she offered us this opportunity
to be like -- start your own
poetry club, you know?  And I
was like... poetry clubs...
[chuckles]... I'm thinking
Shakespeare and Robert Frost and
like huh, huh, huh... this is so
cool.
[ Laughter ]
And we were not entertained.
And honestly it didn't seem like
around to.  I felt limiting, you
know.  And this idea of spoken
word poetry came about and she
brought these artists to the
building to present their
program to us.  To kind of give
us a buy-in, this is why you
should house our program.  And
there was an artist, Rasheed Con
Coneland and he did an amazing
poem about his sister.  I watch
watched myself and friends, we
were theater kids.  We were a
little giggley and we were like,
we can't sit still, we can't
help ourselves.  About three
minutes, this poem was no longer
than three minutes, we were
stuck.  We were encapsulateed in
emotions.  We understood his
relationship with his sister by
the end of the poem, and we sat
around together, more so me
because I kind of dragged all my
friends into this poetry club
business, and we were kind of
like, we can do this.  And at
the time, our high school, as
minority students over in
Woodrow Wilson senior high
school there wasn't a big place
for us in our musical theater
program.  It was unfortunate,
but we had -- we felt like we
had all this art in us and no
place to put it out.  We were
like, Spoken Word sounds nothing
like monologues to me, you know?
This sounds like something I can
do, you know.  And personally I
was jazz trained and singing, a
lot of friends were trained in
singing and we found all these
places where all these different
art forms can meet in lyricism,
simply lyricism.  Call it poetry
feels like.  Let me let you feel
it too, you know.  So we started
this poetry club and spoken word
was our thing, we taught
ourselves how to do spoken word
poetry and we prideed ourselves
in how far we had come with it
and this new era, this new lane
opened up.  It went from spoken
word poetry, we went from poetry
on the page, all that good stuff
stuff, to like this cool modern
twist on it, you know, more
vocal, more active, to this
competitive part, right?  Mind
you, we're theater kids.  We
don't do sports.  We don't have
a sports team that we can, like,
like... competition, you say?
And slam poetry came into play.
basically individual students,
groups of students, teams,
whatever, get together in a
community setting, like an open
mic but instead of everybody
going on stage and just, you
know, delivering their emotions
or their pieces, we add a little
we say, how much effort did you
put into it?  Did you really
believe the words you said?
Have I heard that poem before?
You know, little -- all these
things start to matter, you know
know, and we start to hold
ourselves accountable for the
artists we're building ourselves
into, and we like that challenge
challenge.  You know, we felt we
challenge for a very long time.
So Split This Rock started, a
bomb DMV competition.  It
started in Chicago among Chicago
city public schools, and it
createed this cool place for all
like -- whelk it is something
like people from southeast,
northeast, northwest, you know,
everyone coming together for a
weekend, one weekend.  So every
high school being present, every
of life from your city is
present.  And they're all in
your age range.  And you guys
are expressing yourselves and
exchanging thoughts and what
your view is on your life, you
know, in the city, and you guys
look around and you're like, wow
wow, we're not so much -- we're
not as different as we thought
we were.  And we have elders --
I call them elders, the teachers
teachers, the sponsors, to be
given that term with respect
because you guys harness an
environment, you as are
responsible for this environment
environment, where students come
part of themselves that in most
cases if they didn't have art
would be silent, you know, would
never be brought to the surface,
you know, and you guys are
delegating and helping them,
holding their hands and letting
them know, hey, I saw a kid who
did a poem like yours.  I think
you might like them.  Go check
them out.  And, look, there's a
bond, across-town bond started
that turns into a friendship
that lasts forever.  So kind of
talk more on what I feel like,
you know, art brings -- arts
programming, it's this
opportunity, you know, for
students to apply to challenge
themselves, you know, to try
community, you know, step
outside of their comfort zone,
because I like to think that a
lot of times artists aren't
always the most -- I don't want
to say "normal people"."  We
don't always, like, fit in all
the time.  And that can be very
very -- you know, it can put you
in a very isolateed place.  It
could be socially traumatic to a
long-term, as you build
yourselves into an adult or
whatever, you have all these
issues, you know, because you
never solved your problem, and
we're having this opportunity to
addressing
issues while they're fresh, you
know, and they're young, and
there are people, sponsors,
teachers, program directors,
there are teaching artists who
are responsible for making sure
that that process goes as less
rocky as possible, you know?
So what I do now is I am a
teaching artist in these schools
schools.  I've gone through the
programs, I have done the slams
and performing and spoken word,
and now I've seen an opportunity
to go back and teach, you know,
students what I know.  I felt
like I made it -- I got so many
opportunities and made it so far
expressing myself.  You know, by
feeling these limits and bonds
fall off of me, that I felt the
need -- I don't know why there's
a student in D.C. who isn't in a
program, honestly.  Or on a real
realer note, I am from D.C.,
third generation Washington,
Washington, D.C., Washington
toneian, and I've grown up with
students with young people, with
over the city, from all over the
country who do have -- who come
from all areas of the economic
ladder, from all areas of
religions and walks of life, all
of any of those things or how
they differentiate, one thing we
to do with our free time.  It's
so easy for us to get in trouble
trouble.  I mean, not kind of
like funny trouble, I mean the
kind of trouble that doesn't
allow us to come home ever again
again, you know.  And as a youth
in the last two years, I've lost
friends, you know, in the
streets and around in front of
their homes, you know, in front
of their neighborhoods and I
think to myself oftentimes, like
if they had a program, if they
had a sponsor, if they had a
mentor, if they had somebody who
could keep their mind and keep
them busy or something else,
would they still be here?  So I
thought, that's the severity and
what we do here.
>> Thank you for that.
[Applause]
>> I really love what you said
about the cross-town bond.  I
know that really well.  And what
I want to paint a picture for
the room is if you haven't been
to one of these poetry slam
competitions, it is the most
supportive house of kids that
you have ever found.  Like I've
been in 2,000 high schools in
Chicago, from every neighborhood
neighborhood, and they are only
supportive of whoever is on
stage even though it's a
competition.  And I've adopted
this -- I use this all the time
because it's a way to so support
struggling but already sort of
of -- I don't want to call it a
milder round of applause, but it
it's like a low hum of support
to let people know you've got
their back.
>> When someone is on stage and
performing and you get really
moved because that's what we aim
your seats.  I'm like, oh, my
God, that was great!
It's kind of disrespectful to
step up in someone's home and be
awesome! And they're still
talking.  We have a thing in our
appreciateed, you are being
received, I am listening.  So
snapping is one thing we do.
Another thing, if you're in a
poetry area, you can do like a
sweet chocolate noise, like if
you have a last piece of
chocolate on a bar and you're
like ummm... we like the sweet
chocolate.  And there's a new
thing that the community has
adapted is an awkward draft, you
like... yes!
Little things.  There are cool
mannerisms we have in the arts
community that are teaching
people how to, like, appreciate
their neighbors, you know, and
how to respect, you know,
someone who is speaking, you
know, all of these -- the parts
of, I don't know, being a
citizen, being humane in the
world.
>> Really lovely. Thank you.
[Applause]
Rhona I think we need a cross-
cross-collaborateive project to
work on, because these guys are
such rock stars and I feel like
we could stackle anything.
We're going to get to a couple
Q&A in a moment. I just am
going to start to once again
knit together this conversation,
which I think is connected, but
you're hearing from different
perspectives about really the
necessity of the arts in
everyone's lives.  And I was
thrilled that Jane Chu talked
about our Any Given Child
program in D.C. that has really
been a work in progress for many
many, many years.  We have a
unique window of opportunity for
every sector of the community
coming together and say, how do
we priorityize arts education in
D.C.? and part of the work to do
that is to look honestly at the
data which -- and data is a
listening tour, hearing
communities, hearing voices,
looking at numbers, looking at
maps of the city and analyzing
the gaps and the saturation
points and also looking at
research and best practice.  It
really kind of marries these
things together.  I would urge
you to keep it on your radar and
that is happening right now that
takes this kind of conversation
and puts it into an actual
structure.  And I think, you
know, if I add anything to this
conversation, you know, I get so
inspired but also I laugh.  I
worked in school districts my
whole life, right?  Working at
central office, they mostly
needed me to be the creative
individual, right?  Bringing a
different kind of solution to a
problem and put that creativity
into a structure, but now at a
performing arts organization
they only need my structure.
[chuckles]
But those that are sort of the
structure heads in the house,
that is important too.  You know
know, I hear Nathan talk, when I
systems, the networks, the role
of mentors, the building of
those constructs is also an art
form and really critical because
concert, right?
So a couple minutes for
questions.  Anyone have
something that they want to
direct to the whole panel or to
somebody individual?  Feel free
to raise a hand or stand up.
Oh, great.  We have a couple mic
mics.  Yes, Jenny.  So if we can
get a mic to come around to the
second row in the middle.  Thank
>> First of all, thank you,
especially to the youngest
members of the panel for your
eloquence and for really walking
We've talked a great deal about
teachers, about institutions,
about individual artists, but I
would love to hear how you feel
parts can be more involved in
the equation, because I think
many of us who have children or
who have children, who have
friends with children in public
schools especially wonder what
their role is and how they can
be active, and your mention of
your mom having these two roles
sort of reminded me to insert
that question into the
conversation.
>> Great. Thank you. Who
wants to tackle this one?
>> I don't mind. I think
parents are a necessity to all
of the process, to -- that they
bridge the gap between the arts
and the education, you know,
they are the story, they are the
themselves in the first place,
and I think the most crucial
part to that, which we lack
frequently is presence of those
parents.  If you know your
student is involved in a program
program, urge yourself, you know
know, urge your student to be,
you know, open to you being
there, you know, show up, you
know, leave them a note and let
them know that you're proud of
them just for, like, prepareing
themselves for the day.  There
are so many ways a parent can
put a foot, a hand, a finger,
you know, in the child's, like,
developmental process, and it
doesn't stop at home.Itis a
constant process until they
leave the nest, you know.  And I
think not just -- not just all
along the way, but with students
students -- I'm sorry, teachers,
I think it's sometimes what we
do is keep the parents away from
because it can be scary to have
the parents around you never
know how they're going to react.
I've dealt with a few scary
parents already in my teaching
years, you know, and I can, you
know, resonate with that.  It
can be very terrifying, but you
have to be open, because those
are the people that made the
student that you love and that
you are watching and is watching
over you, you know.
>> Really carveing out that
role
and including them as well.
>> Definitely.
>> I can share a personal
example.  I'm from the Ukraine
and started lessons at age 7, as
first five years I took lessons
my grandma was in there every
lesson writing in a red notebook
that I still have, very large,
hard to read handwriting, taking
and then I was required to
review it when I came home.  And
definitely formative for me.  I
feel very lucky.
>> One more response for the
panel.
>> From an institutional
standpoint, what are the
mechanisms we can put in place
when it's difficult for parents
to show up?  So how do we find
ways to support them?  How do we
Because sometimes they can also
feel like arts -- after school
arts programming can start to
feel like day care and there's a
institutions like public schools
that often have sign-out systems
for young people because of
protecting them, can we
institute that, so the parents
have to come in and just brief
as that is, have point of
contact and engagement.  And
also we start looking at young
people that become deeply
invested in artistic practice
and considering that for their
futures, how do we support them
in the tough conversations with
their parents that sometimes are
fearful of what a future in the
arts looks like.  The future in
the arts looks like this, it's
bright and beautiful and support
supported.  It's not easy but it
it's viable.  And so I totally
understand.  My parents were not
sold on it for years even when I
was making money as an artist,
they still were not sold on it.
helped support that conversation
conversation, we as institutions
ways to help smooth that as well
as inviting them in and trying
to get them to be present.
>> Thank you. Great. Another
question, looks like you're
ready over here.
>> Yes, I have two questions,
if that's okay, and the first
question is directed to Jane Chu
>> Nope.
>> Well, maybe somebody can
answer, because I wanted to know
know, the first question is, I
wanted to know the status of the
National Endowment of the Arts,
because when 45 was elected, I
think he announced he was going
to get rid of the National
Endowment of the Arts.  I was
signing petitions to keep it,
National Endowment of Humanities
Humanities, public broadcasting
corporation, if any of you can
answer that question.  The
second question I guess would be
directed to Mr. Alexander.  It
was a beautiful presentation you
the brain and I wanted to know
if you've done any studies on
the effect of music and the arts
arts, but particularly music, on
necessarily Asperger's but kind
of in the medium of the spectrum
spectrum.
>> Great. I know we can
address question two.  So we're
going to focus on that one and
maybe there can be a sidebar
with the panel about the first
one.  Alex, you want to take
that?
>> Absolutely. So there are
already a number of studies that
And the timeing of your question
for me is very apt.  I'm
exploring a research study at
Johns Hopkins, my institution,
as we speak, with the Kennedy Kr
Kreiger Institute and oother
partners.  We have an interested
exploring that now.  Until now,
my work as a movement disorders
neurologist has focused on the
other end of the spectrum, aging
aging.  So I have done a study
called Parkinsonics using group
choir singing to improve
communication, get the voice
louder and clearer in patients
with Parkinson's, so we're
submitting that for publication
in a few weeks.  To give a
broader context, I've been very
fortunate to help establish and
lead at Johns Hopkins our Center
for Music and Medicine, where we
seek to make music and rhythm an
integral part of healing illness
across the age spectrum.
>> Great. And, you know, it's
interesting, performing arts
organizations definitely across
the district and across the
country really are thinking
about how to create more relaxed
settings, whether it's an
autistic child or other barrier
to really participating as an
audience member but there are
relaxed performances to welcome
folks in.  Unfortunately we are
right about time and we're going
to end with a performance.  I
wonder if you'll indulge me.
I'm furiously taking notes
because I look for themes from
the conversations, so I end up
with five bold words, but I have
Though I tried to get them down
to 10.  This is what I would
like to leave you with before we
leave with another song.
So this cross-town bond I love.
think voice was just across this
whole panel.  Evidence,
ancestors, language, tools,
literacy, produceers of culture,
trust, and then I love -- I
think this is Asha "finding a
home in the library"," which I
think we did today, right?
So can we do a beautiful round
of applause for this wonderful
panel, please.
[Applause]
>> And we would like to give a
thunderous round of applause for
more piece for us.  Thanks again
again.
[Applause]
>> Hey again. I'm back.
>> All right!
>> Yep.
Okay.  So I will play one more
piece for you.  It's one of my
compositions, actually.
So this
one is called "Headlights"."  I
hope you enjoy.
[Applause]
>> Thank you!
>> Thank you, Jose!
>> Sorry. Before I say "bye"
to everybody, before I'm leaving
leaving, I will give a quick
message to everybody that is
here.
This is a really
important message.  And it's
going to help you and it's going
to change your life.  So here it
is...
Be brave.  Always.  When you are
you.  And you're not going to do
a lot of things in your life.
You always have to practice, re
rehearse, be good with the
people, and be brave.  The brave
important for you because it's
going to help you to get a lot
of things and it's going to help
you in your life, because maybe
you're going to have some
challenges.  And that important
things is going to help you to
get that challenge out of your
life.  So stay with this phrase
phrase...
"Be good.  Be brave.  And re
rehearse a lot"."
God bless you.  And thank you
very much, everyone!
>> Thank you!
[Applause]
>> So we're going to -- thank
you again, Jose! Marvelous!
We're going to take about a 30-
30-minute pause, but I don't
want to call it a "break" break,
because when Sue was speaking
earlier and enticeing you a bit
about all of the treasures and
magical things that are in the
collections of the Library of
Congress, we have a few of them
next door.
So in the room right next door,
colleagues of ours from the
American Folk Life Center, which
Congress, as well as our Music
Division, as well as our Prints
and Photographs Division, they
brought some examples of the
library's artistic collections.
And I really, really hope you'll
take some time to stop by next
door and take a look.  The rest
rooms are right around the
corner near where you came in,
and please be back in your seats
right at 11:30 so we can get the
second panel started.  Thanks.
...
Test
>> If everybody could start
moving toward their seats, we're
going to get started in three or
four minutes.  Thanks.
>> Hello. Can everyone take
their seats so we can start with
panel 2.
Now we're just about ready to
start with panel 2.  But before
we begin, I just wanted
to
acknowledge the Arts Commission.
Thank you.
It was through Ann that the arts
education policy that we started
ten years ago came to fruition.
So thank you.
And now without further ado we
will start panel 2.
Okay.  Hello again!
I hoped that after coffee and
stretch time folks come back.
Thank you core coming back.  I'm
LeeAnn Potter, I direct
educational outreach here at the
Library of Congress and a couple
of months ago when Rhona and I
started brainstorming, what this
symposium would do, we agreed
that it should answer
essentially four questions.
Maybe three questions.  I'll get
to the fourth.  We thought about
why.  We thought about how.  We
thought about what.  We thought
about all the good questions.
And as far as the "why" goes,
what we were thinking about was
why arts education matters, and
I think the first panel
certainly did an excellent job
addressing the "why."  Our hope
with regard to the "what" was
that some of you would be
thinking, what does the Library
of Congress have to do with arts
education?  It's not immediately
the first place we think of when
we think of the arts.  So our
hope was when you had a chance
to see some of the items from
the library's collection and
hear what else is in the Lynn's
collection, that the "what does
the library have to do with arts
education" would become more
clear.  I hope that happened.
Did anybody happen to see
something you weren't expecting
to see?
Good.  That was kind of the
hope, that you would see things
you hadn't expected would be
here.
The next question is really the
question that our second panel
is going to focus on this
morning, and that question is
the "how."  So how do these
amazing resources that live in
the collections of the Library
of Congress, how can they be
incorporated into arts education
in ways that are truly
meaningful and truly inspiring?
And so we have a marvelous
panel, and I'm going to start by
introducing you to a colleague
of mine, Ray white is a senior
music specialist in the
library's music division, and he
is actually -- when I say this
is a panel, I got to be honest
with you, it's really not so
much a panel as it is a
performance, a panel, and a
performance.  So our first
performer is my colleague Ray
White and Ray is going to do a
performance for you that I hope
will get you thinking much the
way a classroom teacher is often
thinking about how do we get
young people to understand that
creativity doesn't just happen,
that it really is a process and
that rough drafts really do play
an important role in creativity.
turn.
[Applause]
>> Thank you very much. What
I'm going to offer up in the
next few minutes are materials
that are housed in the library's
music division.  They're among
our great treasures, and they do
demonstrate the creative process
at work.  Now, perhaps many of
you may be familiar with the
song "My Favorite Things" from
the sound of music, and perhaps
the sound that runs in your
brain when you hear that is
Julie Andrews singing it.  But
suppose she's saying this, which
Oscar Hammerstein wrote before
what he wrote what you probably
remember.
raindrops and roses and
whiskers on kitten
these are a few of the
favorite things that I like
[ Laughter ]
Oscar Hammerstein was on his way
where he was going, but he was
not there yet.
[ Laughter ]
Also, from
the same show there's
the famous song called doe
re mi, and Oscar started out
with the idea he was going to
find some word to make
each of
those syllables into a phrase.
arrived.
do is a very young female deer
ray is a light from the sun
mi is a thing I call myself
far is a very long way to run
tea you drink when taking eat
now we come right back to do
You have to figure out that when
you get "sow"... sowing wheat, I
don't know who would have
thought of that.
Now we shift
gears to
irvinBerlin, whose materials
also reside at the library, and
one of the things that his
materials for God bless America
demonstrate that depending on
the time and circumstances of
someone's creativity, their
creativity product may vary.
The short story about God bless
America is it was originally
written during the closing
months of World War I.
It was
an all soldier's review called
yipyap, at long island.  He
wrote this thing called "God
Bless America."
He also decided it was too
anthem-like to be the end of
this vaudeville show, so she put
it aside and came back in 1938
and revised it when
circumstances had changed.
But this is what he first wrote.
God bless America
Land that I love
Stand beside her
And guide her
to the right
with the light from above
and right as political
orientations were not in common
parlance, and all he meant was
"guide her to the right path"
which is fine, but guide her to
the right with the light from
above... and then he decided 20
years later, fixing it up, it
became guide her through the
night with the light from above,
which is just plainly better
poetry.
So there went that change.  But
the song keeps on going.  And it
continues like this...
"Make her
victorious"
"On land and form"
Now, the part you are running in
your head was probably the
mountains and the prairies an
the oceans white with foam.
Well, that didn't exist in the
early one.  "Make her
victorious" because the United
States was in a war at the
time,
but "on land and foam"...
Foam has to rhyme with home, I
get that part, but then he -- in
1938 he went back in the
mountains and prairies and the
oceans white with foam... okay,
that's an acceptable line.
But
we got the foam and the home,
and then he finishes up with
this end, which I find a little
bit musically awkward, dare I
say it.
Ready?
"God bless America...
My home sweet home ""
Now, I say again, I don't think
there's anything at all wrong
with writing something that is
clumsy or awkward or inelegant
or whatever you want to say in
the creative process as long as
the creative process continues
along.  And it gets to where
it's -- it ultimately is going
to go, which points out to me
that music writing is part art
and part craft.
And our last
example is also from Irving
Berlin, his 1946 show "Annie Get
Your Gun."  If you have seen
that show or know about it, you
know it's about Annie Oakley,
the 19th century sharp shooter
and her friends Buffalo Bill and
Charlie and Frank butler and
they want her to join the
western show.  They sing a song
"no business like show business"
telling her how great show
business is.  So as the song
goes on and the verses progress,
then she kind of joins in with
him, and when they get to the
reprieve, she sings it herself,
no business like show business,
let's go on with the show.
Well, there were a lot of words
that Irving Berlin wrote for
this song that didn't make it to
the final stage either, and bear
in mind that the ones that we're
going to share with you now are
in that category.  Before we do,
though, I would like to
introduce my colleague, Steven
Usco, who joined at the piano
for this performance.  Thank
you, Steve!
[Applause]
Imagine if you will these three
guys and then ethyl
Meman,
there's no business like show.
"There's no business like show
business
Like no business I know
Management complaining of the
grosses
Giving you that cake routine
And the leading man that gives
you doses of Halleytosis at
every scene
There's no people like show
people
They smile when they are low
Shows are so expensive
There's an awful nut
Instead of closing you take a
cut
Everyone gets paid except the
actors but...
Let's go on with the show!
There's no business like show
business
Like no business
I know
Notices that give you such a
blasting
Written by a critic with a
grouch
And the stage director
everlasting
Who does his casting
Upon a couch
There's no people like show
people
They smile when they are low
Living with your husband in a
cheap hotel
The stork is coming
You feel like hell
Doctors in the dressing room
But still they yell...
Let's go on with the show!
[Applause]
>> Thank you very much.
>> Oh, that was marvelous.
Thank you, Ray. terrific!
So our next two panelists, and
I'm going to go kind of this
way... our next two panelists
represent organizations that are
part of the teaching with
primary sources consortium.  For
more than ten years the Library
of Congress has been receiving
appropriations from Congress
that have been directed to the
library for us to redistribute
as grants to organizations to
develop curriculum and to make
available professional
development opportunities for
teachers.  Today we have 29
different organizations all
around the United States who are
receiving grant funding from the
library for all kinds of
programs.  Not all of them are
specifically connect to arts
education but two of the
programs that are represented
here today are.  Erin Elman is
going to be our first speaker
and Erin is currently the dean
of continuing studies at the
University of the arts in
Philadelphia and I'm going to
letter intake it from here.
>> Okay. I'm going to do a
little bit of a PowerPoint.  How
do I move this?  Just...
Okay.  Hello, everyone! I want
to just say how inspired I have
been and, Ray, that was a really
tough act to follow.  I don't
sing.  I'm a visual artist.  But
I'll start out by saying that I
am really honored to be here and
I'm going to -- I've been so
inspired by the first panel I'm
going to shift things up a
little bit in my presentation.
I may not get through all the
slides but I think you'll enjoy
it more.
So just to give you a context of
who we are at the University of
the Arts, we're in Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania.  We are a small
private art institution that
houses all of the arts, visual,
performing and creative writing.
nation to devote ourselves
exclusively to the arts.  There
are 1800 students that are
studying graduate and
undergraduate programs.  And I
represent the dean of continuing
studies, so what is that?
That's another 2900 students
that are the learning continuum
from very young people that do
out of school programs on
Saturdays and credit their
programs in the summer for high
school students.  We have
enrichment programs for adults.
But we also have about 1,000 in
service K12 teachers that come
to us to study programs, the
summer music studies programs.
Johanna actually teaches in and
is part of that program.  We
have a professional institute
for educators, and in the music
program and the professional
institute programs we have
non-matric and matric courses
for educators.  So in that
program is the teaching with
primary sources program, and
just to give you a little bit of
a history, back in 2010 we saw
an RFP for an organization to
deliver opportunities to develop
curriculum and professional
development experiences for K12
teachers, and one of my
colleagues saw it and said, Ann,
we have to apply for that, we're
just perfect.  I said, yes, but
we're really at capacity, how
much more can we do?  We have
2500 students.  She said, how
could we not?  I said, how could
we not?  We were thrilled we
were selected to be part of a
consortium.  And what was really
exciting to learn was that the
other consortia members across
the United States working on a
lot of different disciplines, a
lot of them history, actually
they themselves had requested an
arts-based partner, because
nobody in the consortium was
doing work in the arts and they
thought that was really
important.  So I just -- this is
where I start talking about what
we heard before.  So when
Christopher said, you know, to
think about the future, a lot of
cultures think about the past.
We actually adopted as our logo
"look back, see further" for a
work with teaching with primary
sources.  That was sort of what
emerged.  When we tried to think
about, how do we encapsulate the
work that we're doing.  So
really we set about creating a
comprehensive program where we
can help educators, K12 service
teachers and librarians really
figure out how they can bring
the arts into their teaching.
And for us it was a little bit
of a journey as well.  Where we
stand right now, where we
developed -- I'll give an
overview and we'll break it down
a little bit.  We offer courses.
They're available for free for
non-credit and we offer graduate
credits and matriculated
students can take these
programs.  We have an overview
course and discipline specific
courses.  We also create some
curriculum guides that come out
of our professional development.
We test them and we develop them
through professional development
and we're going to have examples
of those on tables when you
leave, if you want to grab one,
you're welcome to it.  We also
try to provide everything -- as
much as what we do online for
free, so a national audience.
And so we have two vehicles for
a web presence, which I'll talk
about later, and then we have a
coaching program, which I want
to mention now, because I'm
going to mention the coaches
throughout the program.  So one
of the things -- and it's
really -- in thinking really --
to be thoughtful about how the
programs live and build and
grow, the consortium and the
Library of Congress decided that
it was really important to
develop high level edge caters
that are really embedded in
these materials so they can
bring them back to schools and
school districts and the
language we develop around them
as coaches.  So we have people
who take numerous courses that
we then put them through their
own professional
development
experience so they can become
leaders in the field.  Here is
where I'm going back to previous
panel.  So thank you panel 1 for
some beautifully illustrating
that.  I'm taking notes during
the first panel.  Of course,
Susan and Dr. Chu really talked
about how important the arts are
and actually noted some key
studies but also, you know, the
arts as a superpower, I love
that, I'm going to use that, and
they have their own language.
And then, you know, Asha talked
about how as a young person the
arts was how she connected
through school.  And we also --
I mean, thank you so much,
Nathan, for the six themes.
Because I think the themes are
embedded in the work that we do,
and it was the way you
articulated them really help us
focus a little more on the
future.  And, of course, those
performances show us how we can
be transformed and moved through
the arts and we're all having
our own personal experience.  So
that's what we're trying to do.
We're trying to say to teachers
across disciplines, it's
important to note that I think
maybe some people, when we --
when I talk about this, people
think, only art teachers take
your courses.  Actually, no, we
have lots of elementary school
teachers and we get gym teachers
that take our program, and
librarians and
discipline-specific teachers.  I
think about 40% of our
participants in our program are
arts teachers, but what is
really important is that they
get to hear the perspective of
the other teachers about how
disconnected and siloed the arts
can feel, and they get an
opportunity to understand how
they can bring history or
science or math into their
classrooms, and so we -- and the
other thing we learned as we've
grown in our program is in the
beginning we started to think
about primary sources in the
arts as the products, but what
we actually -- actually what Ray
illustrated is it's actually the
stuff behind the scenes that can
teach us a lot more about the
arts.  So we can look at, you
know, choreographic notes, the
library has a beautiful
collection of, or musical
notation or notes from a drama
or sketchbooks or notes of an
artist.  So those are all the
reasons why we think it's
important.
So the way we developed our
program is we have two different
types of courses, and I listed
these here.  I'm not going to go
through them.  I'm hoping that
the PowerPoint will be made
available later so people can go
back to it, but we have overview
courses and discipline-specific
courses.  And the overview
courses generally are about 40
to 45 participants and they're
very field trip and lecture
based.  We don't do that much
hands-on, a little bit.  And
discipline-specific course is
through more of a focused study
in the discipline.  I'm going to
talk first about the overview
courses.
So in those courses -- all of
the courses run five days,
Monday through Friday, 8:30 in
the morning to about 6:00 at
night.  They're super-packed and
energizing.  We get teachers
from across the country, people
from San Francisco, people --
because they're free, sometimes
teachers use it as an
opportunity to get to
Philadelphia and we can help
them find, you know, low cost
accommodations.  But we spend
the first day really introducing
primary sources and copyright
and why is it important to
choose primary sources.  I think
what we were surprised to learn
is how many people that take our
classes don't actually know
about the digitized collections
of the Library of Congress in
subject matter, let alone the
arts.  So that's really sort of
an opportunity for them though
get comfortable with their
searches and understand a little
about the framework.  Then we
also talk about this wonderful
tool which is in the guides that
we're handing out and online on
our websites, and it's sort of
this -- a framework for observed
question and reflect and it
walks you through it.  There's
one specifically for frames and
photograph, but there's more
general ones and we use that, we
use it as exemplars, and we have
always have great lectures that
come in and talk about arts and
primary sources and make those
connections.  We're in
Philadelphia, so there is no
lack of amazing collections and
we utilize as many of them as
possible.  Then we ask our
teachers to share out and they
post, so there's an opportunity
for them to do their own
reflection, and then they create
primary source sets through one
of the Library of Congress
tools, which I'll talk about
later, which they can utilize
later.  So very briefly, this is
a course we developed last
summer.  So how many of you have
heard of Steam?  Yeah, I got the
right audience.  So I have...
We decided to say, well, what
kind of Steam objects,
collateral, art projects are
available to the Library of
Congress that can be tied into
all different disciplines?  And
so we were so lucky.  How many
of you know that the Library of
Congress actually has teachers
in residence?  See, they do! And
they're great.  And one of the
ones was Trey Smith, he has a
science focus and I met him here
at the library for one of my
consortia meetings and I said,
okay, we have to work with him.
So he did a presentation and it
was wonderful and he did some
analysis and he really -- even
though he's a scientist, he was
able to find examples of Steam
objects, and then we invited
in -- we talked about -- we
invited in two teaching artists
who came in, Ben Bolter, you can
see his image on your left.  I
think that's right.  He's a
muralist, but works with science
and STEAM as motivation for
students, kindergarten through
12th grade to think about ideas.
Washington, D.C. and worked with
NASA and he came in and talked
about his practice and his work,
and then we
also had another
teacher who talked about her
work and actually did a project
with teachers, and then we also
brought in artists who brought
us to the studios, this artist,
Diane is fascinating, 35 years
she's been flying all over the
world photographing climate
change, really out of her time
and taken the photographs and
turned them into prints and she
lectures and invited to the
White House to talk about her
work.  And so we had all of
these artists in as we also
visited lots of primary source
locations as we keep visiting
the Library's collection online.
And so that's an example of one
of our overview courses.  We'll
talk about this one because it's
not there yet, but just a plug
if anyone wants to join us.
This year we're developing
another overview course called
City of the primary source and
looking at urban planning and
architecture and cartography and
reaching out to people across
those disciplines to develop
that curriculum.
In our discipline-specific
courses we do a deep dive.  So,
again, five days.  What that
looks like is the first day is,
you know, what is the primary
source, how do we use it, what
is online and what is in the
collection?  What is different
about this class is that the
participants will actually study
one particular discipline and
they will actually create studio
projects in that discipline, so
it's important to note they're
not artists, and so they're
drawing or painting or screen
printing for the first time, and
so the ideas that they're doing
projects that they can model
with their students who may not
have comfort in those
disciplines, and then on day
five they develop a lesson plan
and share it out and we have an
exhibition.
So two courses that you can grab
these educator guides, they both
have guides, one was photography
and identity, so identity was
mentioned today as an important
factor for art-making.  And we
used one of the first Lynns in
Lynn --
first libraries in America, a
place to look at early
photographs, and then that
middle image, the images that
they make themselves in the
class.  And then on the left
side is the Library of Congress,
and the Library Company image.
>> Ann, you have another
minute.
>> Okay. I'm going to go
quickly and say that we also
create these guides, and I
didn't -- I brought 50 of each
of them, if you want to grab
one.  They're available free
online.  So you can download
them or you can contact us, but
these are materials that you can
see an example of it.  They go
through the exercise of
analyzing primary sources, and
we have our web presence.  I
think just to conclude what I
wanted to say was that this is
an important moment in, and
preaching to the choir is
important for two reasons.  One
it lets us be agents of sharing
with colleagues and coworkers
that may not have access to some
language and vocabulary around
what we all do, but it also
gives us resources to do what we
do a little bit differently.
So thank you all and I was very
proud to be here today.
[Applause]
>> So I mentioned primary
sources consortium and the next
speaker comes from another one
of our consortiums, member
organizations, and that is the
National Association -- excuse
me -- I've got the -- you know
how acronyms do that to you.  So
anyway... Johanna Siebert is
here today to talk with us about
a really special project
involving the new national
standards for music that were
recently developed by NAFME.
>> Thank you. The National
Association for Music Education.
You can understand it can be
used in a lot of ways.  So I
will slip back and forth between
the two, I think, as I talk.
But thank you very much and
thank you for having us here
today.  I'm the project director
for this project that you're
going to hear about today, and
let's get used to this.  Here we
go.
And so in our collaboration with
the Library of Congress, a good
friend, colleague and director
at NAFME wrote a proposal, you
can see on the screens pretty
much what it is what we want to
do through the grants available
to us.  And so looking at the
three-year program we just
completed, this past summer,
study curricular units, not a
curricula itself, but in music,
right now as we speak I'm
receiving emails with draft
units for band and orchestra and
new teams writing them, and in
the third year we'll be looking
at composition and theory as
well as popular music on how we
can access the multiple
resources that we actually just
got done looking at, as well as
many, many more.
Behind the whole idea of these
new national standards is the
idea of building student
artistic literacy.  We've heard
that word this morning.  Many of
you are nodding.  Many of the
things that have been said
already really validated the
standards and the collaboration
we now have here at the library.
children is huge.  It's not just
knowing about music, but it's
about being in the music or in
any other art form.  And so we
think about all of these and we
still know we have to keep
bringing in all that knowledge
and skills in the past because
as we heard this morning, there
is a lot of skill basis in music
and it be taught sequentially.
We can't lose that.  And that's
what a lot of teachers are very
comfortable with.  So we've been
working on these and kind of
been learning as we go.  As we
see a shift to a process-based
literacy piece, you're looking
at the four major processes we
talk about.  We heard about how
there are steps to this and
composing and improvising and
arranging, whether talking pre-K
level.  Sure, switch the opening
routines, or college-bound
seniors that will major in
music.  We talk about
performing, which the music is
what we're known for, what we
do.  Responding is our focus
area for this unit but we heard
this morning about another
process and how important
personal connections from
students through the arts to
other arts to other areas in
their lives and to other
disciplines are important.  So
to show you all the things we
need to think about, we have
five sets of standards in the
new arts standards.  So we talk
about general music from pre-K
up to grade 8, grade by grade
with successes, ideals of what
we believe, literacy would look
like in those grades,
traditional and emerging
ensembles, big choruses, bands,
orchestras, and all the
different kinds of ensembles you
can think of.  We talk about
comp or theory, writing and
analyzing of music, harmonizing
instruments, making the bridge
between students' music of their
eyes and student music they're
playing in school, you know, via
guitars, United Kingdom lay
Lees, other harm nicing pieces
and other technology.  As these
were rolled out in 2014 and
continue to be now, we found
that teachers really needed to
have some extra resources.  So
during that period and even as I
say up to this state, we are
focusing at NAfME how we can
help that.  In order to
understand, I'm walking you
briefly through our standards,
which would take another three
days, but you can see laid out
here the processes that we are
talking about creating, studying
at the pre-K level will that
kind of writing or talking that
I heard about this morning is
exactly what we mean and having
students be able to go through
the four steps in an order, is
often how we make sure they are
writing, they're refining.  When
students perform they do just
that.  We help their analyzing
and interpreting the music they
choose to perform.  They
rehearse an evaluate themselves
and refine what they do so they
are ready for the last stage to
present it.
Of course, the facilitation of a
teacher and guided by the
teacher but eventually taking
this process on.  And the
responding is a little
different, even though the
little block looks the same.
The components talk a lot about
how students respond to the
selection, analysis and
interpretation and evaluation of
other people's musics.  Whether
it's music they listen to in a
performance or another
composer's music.  Not
necessarily what they're going
to create themselves as
performers.
What you see across the bottom
is the black that talks about
connecting.  We talk about how
we relate to things and how we
inner-relate to things through
music for students.  So you see
really the gamut of what we have
and how using these we hope are
going to help us develop
students into that music
literate performer and thinker.
As we focus on responding, the
idea is that if we help students
understand and evaluate how the
arts convey meaning, and you can
see here the definitions and
what it looks like in those
four -- not necessarily
successes or linear components.
But the ideal, again, is how do
we get to this?  What are the
things we're using for this?
The problem that we've had is
that in ensembles, harmonizing
music and some classrooms they
don't lend themselves to the
study of responding.  And we
need to make that happen for
teachers.  Heavily based on
skills, instruction,
development, maintenance, and
all of those things.  So where
does the talk time come to
respond to music?  If the goal
of class is to perform
something, what are they basing
that on?  How do we help
teachers find time to realize by
focusing and responding we can
help them be better performers.
And as we think about assessment
in any field... woo! I think of
120 students in a course I used
to supervise and I thought, how
are you knowing what each one
knows?
Typical problems that we've had.
resources here from the Library
of Congress, we're working to be
able to take the responding
components that we've looked at
and now after students have
responded and had the chance and
the opportunity to listen deeply
and to think about how music
came to be written and
performed, now apply that in a
performing strand, if you will,
so students are relying on what
I like to call reference points.
As I go to interpret a piece of
music, oh, this is how this was
interpreted and now I have it in
my head that I can draw upon.
So by using the mission
statement of a Library of
Congress we find that these two
fit very well together.  By
addressing a learning and
knowledge and history and
relevance of all of what we've
been talking about this morning
and seeing in the room next door
and throughout the building, we
tie that to how students use
that creativitily and how they
use it also in performing,
composition and analysis.
So work of writing teams.  We
looked at music 2, 5, 8 this
past year.  We have units in
those.  We have units in chorus,
the five levels you have,
gradually progressing levels
that don't necessarily focus on
a gray level because the
ensembles don't meet that way.
They meet as choirs or as a band
or ensemble with all bit on
audition students and it can
look different from one district
in the country to another, from
urban to rural to suburban
settings.
You're going to respond in
standards.  We've been able to
guide instruction via the
inquiry models that are part of
the grant proposal and using
that through the Library of
Congress.  We have our own
essential questions embedded in
the national standards as well
as enduring understandings.
So I want to talk to you and --
make sure you keep me on my
time.
>> You're getting close.
>> This is one of the grade 2
units.  It talks about our
objective through our TAM
statements, this is what
students in school are using
throughout the country.  A dance
unit or a movement unit.  The
essential question:  How are
music and movement alike?  Why
does music make me move or
dance?  You can see performance
standards listed as well.
So the opening activity that a
teacher would lead would be
reviewing some skills and how do
we move, what are different ways
to move?  She would extend it by
asking them to add new movements
to the piece and think about how
they walk and, again, vocabulary
ready for students at that age.
The opening activity -- John is
going to help in the back.  I
like it.  By clicking on one of
the jukebox recordings that she
used as the introduction.
Thanks, John.  Go ahead.
>> Thank you, John. So we'll
keep it short so you can hear.
You couldn't imagine
second-graders reacting to that,
sometimes we wish they weren't
reacting to that.  What that
would be like.  And you can see
also -- I'm wondering, do I need
to click ahead?  I'm looking
back to...
Thank you very much.  The
questions that she's asking
through various types of
prompting and inquiry are kind
of those things, and she was
using a visual thinking model.
It looks a little different in
chorus.  In chorus we talk
about, what could this be like?
This intermediate level now for
the most part middle school
students, depending when they
start chorus in a district like
yours.  All the units there are
focused on multiple things.
This level we focused on folk
music and you saw a lot of
materials next door about that.
High school level they focused
on spirituals.  So we know
students will be singing
spirituals sometime throughout
their career.  They use the
Socratic circle model and
includes outside work.  I'm not
going to click on the link now
because I want to make sure that
you have access to this
PowerPoint and it will be
embedded for you.
So I think what we're showing
you is that through what we talk
about these processes become
interdependent much as literacy
is dependent upon many other
things as well.  As we look at
the practices you see here, we
know to truly pulled
understanding that we want
students to be able to transfer
what they've learned to new
situations and learnings and
experiences so their learning
continues to grow.  It shows us
more and more the rigor of what
we can accomplish by going
through stages like this and
connecting some of the
responding artifacts, lessons
that in turn will help students
focus on their own performance
and make all their ensemble work
even strong per
stronger.
You can see one of the things
worried about is the time it
will take in choruses and large
ensembles and the person's
testament here talked about how
she could fit these into her
daily routine, and the units
show that.
The students loved it.  One of
the comments they made you'll
understand because you just
heard the run-run-run example.
They talked about in that old
school music sound, thinking
that's how we all learn music or
through scratchy recordings, so
a little disk agography gets
taught at the same time.
These units we made available to
everybody.  We were just talking
about having people enroll in
the courses.  We recently
presented our grade 8 general
music unit, a national social
studies conference.  I watched a
colleague who was presenting
with me and we were meeting in a
poster sex and -- a poster
session.  She
started taking down requests for
different periods of time that
the social studies teachers
wanted so they could connect it
to music.  They were doing it
already.  I guess we have a few
more things to think about this
third year as we start writing
these.  The units are available
at that website or just go to
NAfME and watch the headers that
go by and you'll see the units
you can link to and use.
Anybody can use these.  You
don't need to be a member.  But
I hope you do.
I guess I'm going to wait for
questions for a little while.
So I hope to hear from you.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
>> Thank you, Johanna. Both
of
the projects, you are doing such
important work and reaching so
many teachers, and the library's
collections as you know come in
a wide variety of media and I'm
really glad you played that part
from the national jukebox.  How
many of you know about the
National Jukebox on the
Library's website, that it has
historical record something now
you do.  There's 38 million
things on the Library's website.
music, sound recordings, really
I hope that after this you all
spend some time doing some
exploring and realize -- this is
a really important part, that
because this is the Library of
Congress, this is our national
library.  All of these resources
are ours collectively.  We
should be making good use of
them.
Okay.  So with that, not only
can the Library's collections be
tremendous teaching tools, but
the Library itself can do.  How
many of you have never spent
time in the Library's Jefferson
Building?
Okay, some of you.  All right.
So as you know, this building
we're in today is not the most
beautiful as the Library of
Congress buildings.  The
building next door, the Thomas
Jefferson Building is quite
extraordinary.  And our next
panelist is Kathy Tuchman, she
works with visitor of services
office here at the library and
has developed a really
extraordinary tour.  This is a
history tour, and some of you
had a chance to visit a little
bit ago in the next room to
share with you the discovery
card, and that's all I'm going
to say.  Kathy, it's your turn.
>> Thank you. I'm just going
to move my stuff over here real
quickly.  My name is Kathy
Tuchman with visitor services
office at the Library of
Congress, and this past year and
a half I've had this fantastic
opportunity to work on two
projects, and a lot of you may
have been able to see the
projects I was working on.  The
first is the explorer, the
building cart, which we had up
earlier.  The visitor services
received this fantastic box of
original materials that we used
in our construction of the
building and my colleague, Megan
White and I worked on this
together.  We went from
researching everything from how
bricks were made to how the
coring methods of granite and
marble, so that way we could
interact and have all the
answers or try to have some of
the answers at least for our
visitors.  A bit of the cart
program you want to know.  It's
a way for visitors to come to
the building and interact in a
totally different way, where
they can get hands-on, feel the
original pieces of the building
and they can ask questions.  A
lot of times people come up and
tell me they were
third-generation carver, they
want to share their experiences
as well.  So it's a really
fantastic experience.  They are
trained on the cart material.
They have gone through a
training program and have a
wonderful manual, and so we're
there to support them.
The other project that I was
lucky to work on this past year
was the history program, the
tour for the blind and visually
impaired.  We in visitor
services have fantastic tours.
We offer constituents, public
reserve tours throughout the
day.  Our dough
Our docents go through a
training program for a total of
150 hours just toshire with you
that this is a well-developed,
well-researched tour, not just
thrown together quickly.  The
docents that are chosen to do
touch history have been docents
at least one year, not
completely new to the program.
The touch history we enhance
verbally our normal tour.  So we
have great history.  That's
similar.  But then we go into
more descriptive ability at the
building, give people -- we
reached out to the capitol and
let them know we were working on
this project and they were
incredibly generous with us.
Many of you saw I have an
original brick here.  A lot of
people don't know that the
Jefferson Building is a brick
building.  22 million bricks
went into the construction of
this building but you don't see
them.  People don't realize
that.  I have a brick, you can
feel it.  It's quite heavy.
Also a piece of the granite.  We
have like a cross-section.  You
have the granite on the exterior
and the brick plaster and then,
of course, the marble.  If
you've been in the building you
have seen we are marble.  That
is just like the icing on the
cake there.  It's marble
cladding.  And this allows
visitors doing a touch history
tour, I can hand it to the
visitors and they can feel and
interact them and feel the
coolness, the smoothness of the
surfaces, depending on their
visual ability they can maybe
want to reach up and look at it
closely.
I want to back up a little also
because I want to talk about the
ceiling, the architecture of
this, which was fantastic.  I
have original pieces of the
marble mosaic, which I didn't
turn over with me, but the
architect -- if you've been in
the building you've seen three
Al coves are
mosaic ceilings and
the architect put them on a
wooden base so we can hand them
out and let the visitors feel
this and get a sense of the
incredible artistry involved in
doing these ceilings.  So that's
just a little about the why and
how we did it.  We also have
been working -- I researched and
went to a lot of museums to see
what they were doing in New York
and here in Washington.  We
researched online to see what
best practices are in the museum
world and doing tactile tours.
Luckily we have a fantastic
EEODP division here, our equal
opportunity disability programs
and we worked with Lorrainea bad
Ford from the National Gallery
of Art and had a wonderful
review with her.
So let me tell you about -- I
told you we do a descriptive.
So let me -- if I can -- this is
going to be fun -- let me give
you a little bit of tour coming
into the building.  If you've
never been in the building this
will be exciting.  So it's
Jefferson -- Library of
Congress -- let's back up, it
was created 1800. first 97 years
were spent in the capitol.
That's where we began.
Then at
that time they could see us
expanding services and wanted a
larger building, so Congress
appropriated the funds to build
the Jefferson Building.  Let's
talk about the Jefferson
Building.  Walk up the grand
staircase and come into the
building, into the first Al
cove, which is Minerva.  There
are four alcoves that surround
the hall.  The first is Minerva.
You walk in and there are eight
pairs of Minerva, goddess of
wisdom and descent of war.  And
walk through one of the three
arches into the great hall.  The
building is fantastic in
symmetry.  On one side, it's
equally on the opposite.  If
it's on the left, it's on the
right.  I love this building.
So we're now standing in the
great hall.  Let's orient
ourselves.  In the great hall.
Lots of sound, really noisy.
The great hall is called that
because it's pretty large.  It's
50 feet across and about 43 feet
from front to the next set of
arches.  It's 75 feet to the
ceiling.  So quite large.  From
where we're standing if we were
to look up we can see up to the
mezzanine level and there is a
marble bannister that runs all
around.  So the mezzanine level
is available to us, the sound of
it, so it's quite loud.  On the
left-hand side of the great hall
the grand staircases, these are
fantastic. about nine feet wide.
And, of course, on the side of
the staircase we could have left
them plain but why would we do
that?  This is 1897, why would
we want to do that?  We have
fantastic sculptures going up
the sides and they are called
pute.  A lot of them refer to
them as cherubs, but like little
babies.  We have four, and then
a landing and four more.  Eight
on the left and eight on the
right.  I'm going to talk about
the four on my left, if we're in
the building.
[ speaker is off microphone ]
>> When you're going up the --
the putie are in a window, like
a little house.  There are four
of them and aligned next to each
other.  The first is sitting on
his knees facing us directly and
in his right hand he has a rake
and a hoe.  Left hand he has a
watering can.  We can see the
water coming out of it.  So he
would be our what?  Our
gardener, correct?  Next would
be our -- he has an angle to us,
this next little putie.  He is
facing the left.  His left hand
is reaching out trying to get to
the gardener and in his right
hand is a butterfly net.  And he
is our entomologist.  We're
showing that the putie have
different occupations and
hobbies or all represented here.
And this is a fantastic thing
for the kids to come and they
can interact and try to show
them which -- what do you think
this putie does?
The last two, one is sitting
there, the last is sitting there
with a book on his lap and he's
a scholar.  And last but not
least would be our printer,
because where would we be
without the library printing.
So we have those on either side
of the building going up.  It's
a great opportunity to be
expansive in description with
our visitors who have visual
impairments and kids when they
come into the building, we can
bring the building to life.
The last thing I want to mention
about the great hall, did I
mention that you can park about
ten cars on the floor of our
great hall?  It's a fun thing to
mention.  It gives you a sense
of the size.  Across from us, I
told you the staircase, but
directly across from the arches
that we're standing at, we have
three more arches.  And I
mentioned the middle arch, we
have the father, the young
and -- the scholars, the young
and old.  Important to mention.
They stand six feet in height.
Young scholar on the left-hand
side, he's leaning into his left
arm.  He has left leg crossed
behind him and looking to his
right.  And, of course, he's
learning.  And on the right-hand
side is our older scholar, and
we know he's old because he has
a beard, his skin is a little
bit looser.  And he has a
tablet.  And, of course, when
the building was built they
might have been implying that
the young scholar had the newer
technology, paper, and the old
scholar had the tablet, but
today the older scholar really
has the latest technology,
correct?
[chuckles]
A good laugh.
To finish a bit of our tour, I
would take us to our left-hand
side out of the great hall into
the hall of the education, into
the hall of family, and I like
to mention this hall because
this one, you come in and it's
about 70 feet long, 20 feet
wide, and it's about 26 feet
tall, about.  It's got an
archway, which is where some of
the beautiful mosaics come in.
They're not only decorative, but
they also have information this
them, and our ceiling, the hall
of the family, we have great
edge day terse, and 1897, the
librarian, the first name is
Howe.  H-O-W-E.  Anyone heard of
Samly Ridley Howe.  Some have.
The first superintendent of the
Perkins School for the Blind,
which is important to note.
Next his name is Gallaudet,
which was the first
superintendent for the school
for the deaf.  In 1897 both the
blind and the deaf were listed
in our building, that's
important.  Also I have to
mention this alcove is the
listing of all the librarians of
Congress that we have, as I love
to mention on our tour, and
visitors are allowed to go feel
this.  When the building opened
in 1897 we had only one woman's
name in the building.  It was
1897, and that was Saffa.  As of
last year we now have a second
name.  Dr. Carla Hayden is
engraved in our building.  It's
really fantastic.  I hope you
enjoyed my little brief tour and
the wonderful opportunities that
we have to engage with visitors
in a whole different way and if
you didn't get to see the CART,
we still have it.  So thank you
very much.
[Applause]
>> Thank you. The Thomas
Jefferson Building Kathy has
been telling you about welcomes
1.5 million visitors a year, and
a few thousand of those visitors
make their way into our young
readers center, which is also a
part of the Library of Congress,
and every Friday morning at
10:30, if you want to see
something pretty spectacular,
you can come to infant and
toddler story time at the
Library of Congress.  And it's
unlike any other program that
happens at the library and you
might say it's a little louder
and some might describe it as
being a little more chaotic.
But late this summer, early this
fall, I was over in our young
readers center and my colleague,
Sasha Dowdy and intern at the
time, Erin Durham, a student at
the University of Maryland, they
were practicing for the upcoming
story time.  And, you know,
storytime always involves songs
and there's always a little bit
of movement, but this was the
first story time that we were
experimenting with bringing
musical instruments into story
time.  And it was really quite
something.  When you're used to
seeing a little bit of chaos and
suddenly a violin is involved,
three-year-olds are mesmerized.
In fact, it would be fun to
mesmerize you guys for a little
bit today and so I invited Sasha
and I invited Erin to come and
share a little bit of musical
story time with you.
>> Hem low.
>> Hello. Thank you Lee Ann.
>> Mole lived all alone
underground.  He spent his days
digging tunnels.
[ violin playing ]
>> At night he ate supper in
front of TV and went to bed.
[ violin playing ]
>> Mole liked that lately he
had begun to feel there was
something missing.
[ violin playing ]
>> One night on the television
the man played the violin.  He
made the most beautiful music
Mole had ever heard.
[ violin playing ]
>> I want to make beautiful
music, too, Mole said to
himself.
>> [ violin playing ]
>> So the next day he sent away
for a violin of his own.
[ violin playing ]
Every day Mole checked his
mailbox.
[ violin playing ]
No violin.
Finally, after nearly three
weeks, it arrived!
[ violin playing ]
Mole was so excited!
He picked up the violin and drew
the bow across the strings...
[ violin playing ]
[ Laughter ]
But instead of beautiful music
all he made was a horrible
screeching sound.
[ violin playing ]
Mole tried again.
The violin still screeched but
not quite so horribly.
Mole kept at it.  After about a
week he could play one note.
[ violin playing ]
Then two.
And before a month went by, he
could play an entire scale.
[ violin playing ]
Mole continued to practice.  He
learned to put the notes
together in a simple song.
[ violin playing ]
Years went by.
Mole got better
and better
[ violin playing ]
He was happier than he had ever
been.  During the day as he dug
tunnels, Mole hummed the music
he would play at night.
[ violin playing ]
Now Mole played even better than
the man he had seen on TV so
long ago.
[ violin playing ]
Sometimes he wondered what it
would be like to play his music
for people.
[ violin playing ]
He imagined himself playing
before a huge audience.
[ violin playing ]
He imagined that he played for
presidents and queens.
He even imagined that his music
could reach into people's hearts
and melt away their anger and
sadness.
[ violin playing ]
Why, maybe his music could even
change the world!
[ violin playing ]
Mole laughed at himself.
How silly I am, he thought.
Imagining that my music could do
all that when no one has ever
even heard it.
[ violin playing ]
Mole played one more song.
Then he put down his violin and
went to sleep.  And dreamed
beautiful, peaceful dreams.
[ violin playing ]
[Applause]
>> We still have three and a
half minutes for questions.
You guys are fabulous.  That was
just great.  Don't you want to
go to story time?
Okay!
It does look like we have a
question over here.
John has a mic for you.
>> Hi! Thank you so very much.
This was a wonderful panel.
Just a wonderful day really.  A
question for you all.  This is a
question that we have been
talking about as a community
very recently.  What does it
mean to be a national
organization serving local
audience?
Maybe some of you could
illustrate a bit of how you're
working specifically with D.C.
family engagement empowerment?
You know, today's conversation
about equity access and
empowerment, how are we or you
as organizations empowering
young students and families to
take full advantage and
incorporate the amazing
amenities and offerings here
nationally to D.C.?
>> Great question. And,
actually, I'm very happy that
you asked it.  So story time
that happens here at the library
is not something that we
livestream.  It's not something
that we make a big deal out of.
And like I said, one of the
reasons why I wanted to invite
Sasha and Erin to do this for
this particular event was to
really stretch the reach of that
program, hoping that maybe
there's an opportunity for some
milk minimumming to go on. --
milk minimumming to go on.  I
know programs like that are
going on over the country, and
we want to showcase some of
that.  We're being live streamed
today and the opportunity to
extend the reach of the programs
at the library by using those
technologies is one of the ways
we're trying to do that.  But
the balance between figuring
out, are you serving a local
audience or national audience,
I'm not sure it's neither/or.  I
think it's a both/and.  I think
there's an opportunity to
recognize that those local
audiences, frankly we have a
team board here at the Library
in our Young Readers Center, and
some of the students we're able
to make available to those young
people, we're trying to figure
out very deliberately, how do we
capture this and make this
available to a much broader
audience, what we've done this
year something sort of new with
that group is asking colleagues
from around the library to come
to each one of their meetings
and share with students some of
the resources that are in their
collections, so that the kids
have a better sense of the
enormity of the place.  And we
need to do that with a much
broader audience.  Really it's
both.  It's both/and.
>> I would say in visitor
services we reach out quite a
bit with a lot of our tours to
invite in the different school
groups.  When we do specific
tours in the exhibitions, like
when we have the Magna Carta
here, we reached out quite a bit
to a lot of D.C. public schools
and invited them in and it was
on a docent-led tour.  We do do
a lot.
>> A million and a half
visitors, they're coming from
all over.
>> And our tours are available
to everyone.
>> I guess one of the things I
think about is, you know, again,
I based a lot of what I talked
about today on the national
standards, and how the
responding being built from
those through resources here,
they can connect to students no
matter where.  Looking at things
like that, we think about how
can teachers personalize it
either to perhaps a culture of a
community if you're looking for
specific musics, intercultural
types activities, too, how can
the teacher take what we're
providing or the different
processes that I mentioned and
make them a little more
appropriate, perhaps, and,
again, by the levels.  Where do
we bring parents in as visiting
artists, when they talk about
music at home.  So I would
suggest they're meant to be
interpreted very widely when
they were written, the standards
that it was meant to reflect a
national look, which is hard to
do in that document, isn't it,
because we look different from
one state and locale to the
next.  But how do we go about
personalizing them would be the
goal.
>> For us it's really that we
do attract educators across the
country to programs summer
intensive that happen in July,
but the guides are meant to
brought back to communities and
the people that don't have the
opportunity to come study with
us and what we hope to do is
encourage them not only to
explore the Library of Congress
collection but find ways in
their own communities, no matter
where you live there's a
historical society or
there's a
cultural central museum and a
lot of museums have materials
that -- what we find is that we
tell people we're bringing
educators, they're so over the
moon.  A lot of cultural
institutions don't know how to
engage with educators, but they
have curriculum and methods,
they don't know how to publicize
that, so we're encouraging
educators across the country to
engage with the cultural
institutions in their own
communities as well as using
what we know is on the Library
of Congress website as a
springboard to then replicate
that in their own communities.
>> Any other questions?
All right, Rhona, it's us.  We
could give you tap dancing and,
you know... and I'll start by
simply saying, thank you all.
Thank you all for coming today.
Our hope is that the
conversations will continue,
that some of you will stick
around and have lunch over in
the cafeteria and visit with
each other and trade cards and
come up with approaches that you
might -- yeah, great! And there
is a question.  Yay!
>> I heard you say that
cultural organizations are going
to work with people and that you
will have some program or
something to help with that
area.
>> Well, we don't have any
specific resources exactly to
connect with crick -- with
cultural organizations.  What we
have is a guide to find
materials that work with
particular curricular areas, but
we have our website that has
resources and lesson plans and
you can call and connect with
the people that are on our team
that can actually give you some
prompts and tell you how to walk
into a cultural organization and
say, this is what my curriculum
is, whatever I'm teaching.  What
do you have in your
collection -- and we give you
tools to start with what is on
the Library of Congress
collection so you know what is
there and you can say, well,
what can my students look at
that might be relevant to our
own community?
>> Can I add on to that?
Sorry.
[ speaker is off microphone ]
>> I just wanted to add on to
that.  Especially talking about
equity and access and how
educators can benefit from all
of these tools but then take
them down to the local level.
The D.C. collaborative has been
working with Nathan Diamond and
the D.C. Arts Team for some time
to find ways how we in the
private sector, all the cultural
institutions here in the
district serving D.C. students
can make curricular connections
to that arts education framework
Nathan was talking about.  So
D.C. has those numbers for
student field trip program and
after school programming and out
of school time programming that
they provide, are now looking at
the -- for curricular alignment,
and we do professional
development opportunities and I
would absolutely welcome a field
trip for us to come up to
Philadelphia so that we can
share that out with educators
here in the District.
>> Okay. So once again, thank
you all for coming this morning.
that you've started and the
conversations that you will
continue.  I also want you to
say "yes, I will."
Thank you.  Good suggestion.
It's like Julia works here.
She's reminding me that after
lunch I ought to head over to
the Thomas Jefferson Building,
you that you have it visualize,
you should see it if you
haven't.  Good suggestion.  I
also want to do a shout-out to
some of my colleagues that have
been incredibly helpful in the
planning of the event and
execution of the event today.
Michael Appledorf or Vivian, and
our teacher in residence, Matt
Poss and I know Dana Bell is
around and Phoebe Coleman, thank
you all for being here and for
all that you do to help
contribute to today.
[Applause]
Thank you Rhona.  My goal for
this was that everybody in the
room would know a little more
about the Library of Congress
than you knew when you got here
this morning and that you might
start thinking of some ways that
your organization or that the
teachers or students that you
work with might benefit from the
Library and its collections in
ways you had never imagined
before, and get to know us.
Because we're a lot of fun and
we've got some really cool
stuff.
>> They are fun.
>> All right. Very good.
Deanna?
[ speaker is off microphone ]
>> And, yes, on your way out
you can snag a terrific
publication called "Lyrical
Legacies" featuring amazing
materials on the website.
Everything in that publication
is online as well.
[ speaker is off microphone ]
>> Get a mic or Don is going to
yell at you.
>> Is this working? Well,
no...
Thank you.
Next door is the cafeteria.
Rest rooms are down the hall and
we hope you will all join us for
lunch.
>> Have some lunch. Thank you.
at the tables and anyone who
wants to network and just
discuss these ideas -- are you
going to be available?
And talk to our panelists, talk
to Lee Ann and myself and thank
you, Lee Ann, again, and Susan
Vita for this wonderful
partnership.
>> This was terrific.
[Applause]